tu as j'ai tout prévu à l'avant sera le
cadrage des caméras et tout mon art venu
bien bien assez vite comme ouais on est
revenues assez vite et par contre j'ai
la mauvaise cam de sauts par contre ça
c'est la gamme de sécurité la sève comme
sa tu vois la can de sécurité comme tu
vois son écran tu es sûr qu'il ait pas
d'oreillettes ou cake quoi que ce soit
il on double le triple double caméra et
ça avec cette caméra en fait t'es sur
qui a pas de triche ah ouais nature à
des sur 1 5% là d'accord ok là ça c'est
le voeu nul qui met en doute richmond à
ses frais de justice
ok certaines parties on est bien sûr
d'accord c'est parfois directement
c'est ça une caméra derrière donc
automatiquement la ccsa doublonnent
l'état deux angles de vue là tu es bien
battu tu vois tout quoi et plus un seul
angle mort dans la pièce à partir
tellement génial c'est son nom est tu là
pour les deux joueurs bien évidemment
sauf carlson qui lui l'avait pas déjà
bien sûr les gens un peu plus que ça me
fait marrer davance ça me fait marrer
d'avancé mais j'espère qu'on va j'espère
sincèrement qu'on va voir un beau match
j'espère sincèrement au flash intégré
c'est pas possible pour le chat
le truc c'est que malheureusement
[Musique]
malheureusement quand même soudé un peu
plus fin oui il semble il semble mais
rapetous à 9
en plus il a exactement le même style
que sow c'est ça qui m'inquiète le plus
c'est que c'est vraiment des copies 4
quoi c'est le même joueur
moins fort ouais du coup ça ça commence
mal enfin on se dit bon bah comment
peut-il rester pas on se dit un peu ça
je te cache pas les ricains sont les
meilleures conditions les autres on s'en
fou d'un keller ils jouent ils ont qu'à
s'adapter c'est pas faux en plus ça va
brasser avec les américains il jouait il
joue à 11 heures 11 heures du mat là
c'est la bonne heure et à la douceur de
la nuit il ya quoi il ya 3 heures wade
doit être 21h mais tu vas tu finis à
00h30 une heure du matin moi j'aurais du
mal tu vois pour un match aussi tendu je
préfère quand même largement jouer le
matin ou l'après midi j'ai pas toi femme
je suis d'accord je le prenne ou début
de soirée les 18 heures mais 20 heures
en fait moi ce serait pas 20h30 je pense
les deux les deux premières heures de
match je les aurai dans les jambes mais
je pense qu'avec une telle intensité
après ça fêtards femme se rend compte de
la prise d'otages ah oui surtout que
j'avais un petit derby ne pas voir un
massacre c'est pas grave je pense que je
pourrais avoir un bout du match mais je
pense que tu es content quand même ne
pas avoir lyon synthé ce soir ouais je
veux pas être là que dans les moments où
ça se passe bien mais bon maintenant oui
de merde on va dire que c'est tata une
belle excuse toi de le rater ah bah là
j'ai pas le choix
oui mais c'est bien page a rejoint tu
t'éclates a la conscience tranquille
voilà exactement ou pas vont m'accuser
de devoir lâcher l'équipe
non mais bon j'en peux plus j'ai encore
vu le groupe des joueurs sélectionnés
j'en peux plus pour le match ouais non
mais je comprends pas ça dépasse - la
compréhension des choses on a vendu pour
plus de 100 millions de joueurs en un an
[ __ ] tu réalisme inouï sortie
comment c'est possible bart annonce
première grosse nouvelle du match pour
bien bien comment ces problèmes de
connexion côté ouzbeks savent à
'conserver'
non non ça ça vient de commencer mais il
a une connexion à deux barres un set
commençait pourtant c'est bien sur mon
écran bêtement un coup de partage où
j'étais to me j'étais toumi confort et
ça commence par une carreaux cannes et
qui est ok on écoute et on écoute et on
écoutait côté mur tu as nancy les
conseils de murtaza il va essayer de
gagner une partie déjà joué vite et bien
et gagner une partie puis une autre à
mon avis c'est vraiment l'objectif de
son match ouais ben écoute audio
quiconque à rock'n learned avance
et puis elle s'est plantée avec son
cavalier en d4 déjà bien placé quoi
alors je réponds à mathieu pernette dans
le chat qui dit que dit mur tu as de ce
jeune alors mur tu as pense qu'il
arrivera jamais à haut niveau paolo
niveau faveur tapas importante à ce
niveau c'est top 10
je pense qu'elle va jamais dans le top
10 parce qu'il dit que tout ce qui s'est
fait ces théories et des chants et
défendre ou patronne 2 et rien en fait
et du coup faire un certain genre de
saut de karuïa qui nous quoi et mirta
s'ils voient pas ce genre de joueur
arrivé au top mais il dit qu'il est très
dangereux en blitz et qui le défonce en
fait très dur de blitz et contre lui me
dit c'est en fait il fait rien de la
partie mais de compte des peaux de
bananes des merdes
ouais donc du coup je vois pas dans quel
monde
enfin sauce ça c'est le pire adversaire
pour sa 9 au sichuan à sarajevo et tiens
regarde on va échanger les la wii bien
sûr mais c'est vraiment le scénario de
match auquel on s'attend d'ailleurs fab
ouais je sais pas trop tu vois je
m'attends mai mais je pense que sow va
gagner tranquillement contre 12 10 un
saut de wisches et c'est ça en plus tu
donnes tu donnerais call score thouars
pronostics combien d'écart +8 plus 10 +
12% contre les vautours de plus dix
autres plus disent ouais peut-être même
plus un d'ailleurs on va voir mais tu
vois abdou il avait gêné en title cuse
et la gêne et plusieurs fois maxime
talbot abdou il aurait plus un style
pour embêter un joueur comme maxime qui
est un joueur offensif maxime ça il le
contrer ou quoi et se met rencontre en
tout cas c'est bien non wei a retoqué en
dessin c'est pas mal il va bloquer la
colonne et c'est en fait de base c'est
assez chiant le fond b6 et les blancs
crapules envers la côte d avec tour des
arts dont les tournages un début qui a
planté un cahier en d5
pourquoi pas il ne va pas tu auras
toujours ses 4 1 peut vérifier mais bon
tous ces huit se tourne ça devrait aller
non je pense pas que ce soit trop mal
non il a pris le temps lui reste plus
que 3 18 mai mais bon ça ça ça semble
suffire et après tu as dis moi c'est
quoi les règles du jeu afin de concevoir
si je vous combien de litres sont 5803
que 800 1 alors je vais rajouter le
timer 1h30 à une heure de 3 + 1 et 30
minutes 2 1 + 1 bien finir on sait pas
mais en réalité c'est sans rigoler ça a
été jusqu'à maintenant la la cadence qui
nous a jamais déçus
ç'a toujours été intéressant en fait
même karl scène par am en réalité car la
scène par amy à 4 2 pour karl scène par
hama une bonne position il est quasi
gagnant il aguiton beau temps quelque
chose comme ça où il ya 3 2 way à 3 2
pour karl scène il aguiton beau temps et
après il c pri 13 01 trucs comme ça
mais en gros tu vois c'était intéressant
les parties s'étaient serrés puis là ok
il a juste lâché mais là j'aime bien ce
que fait apple ou non ça va il est pas
mal
j'ai pas mal voilà un nul c'est normal
mais je pense qu'il va je sais pas si
abdou sow torah va gagner beaucoup de
partis mais ce dont je suis sûr c'est
qu'il va attirer beaucoup de nulle part
beaucoup nul peut-être six ou sept dans
le match voilà en gros c'est du solide
et sous écrou aucun risque mais là c'est
bien ce qui fait ce qu'il peut presser
ses quatre bâches katché pas surtout
demandé d'en acheter un casque car j'ai
pas aimé h5 j'ai bien aimé mais pas
atteint l'âge 5 s'il veut se lancer que
vous lâche 5 tours à 6 tours j'ai six
tours g4 je pensais qu'il voulait faire
ça mais là maintenant il a plu tour ses
six tours s'est vite ouais c'est
catastrophique bon première défaite mais
je pense en fait je vois pas comment tu
défends bof
la grèce n'est pas genre x 7 x 7 la
menace ouais mais bon peut-être qui veut
se venger sur cinq après mais quoi qu'il
en soit avec les plantes est peut-être
déjà pas mécontent des déséquilibres et
ça te faire une majorité sur une allée
puis puybouffat t'avoue perd 2,5 sur a
gagné 4 ça va aller non il est bien pas
bien chaud le pion à jusqu'à ce qu'il
est vraiment dramatique en fait juste
même dans les variantes tu pourrais très
active avec latoya tout reprend h4 tu
vas partir d un talent tu fasses 4 ou
quoi nous tue votre nomination
oui mais j'ai en fait oui oui bien sûr
mais tu as déjà peut-être à mais encore
à 5 ans la rue jarry terre je peux
manger ses 4 h 4 mai mangera 1,5 et h5
on tour
est-ce que ce poste déjà où il ya une
couille
parce que bon résultat ici je peux faire
efficace je le ferai bien moi aussi bon
pourquoi pas clichy ya peut-être un truc
avec quatre ans soit sa marotte a dû le
faire des g5 et pourquoi pas dès ce 4 g
5 m de toute façon ou et cela il doit
savoir comme nous cap 12 son gros point
fort c'est des pièges
donc il doit être méfiant quoi mais même
si un joueur du top mondial je pense
qu'il doit de bien sûr ouais bon bain
peut-être a fait quatre ans que je suis
en tout cas s'il fait pas 10 4 ce qui
les attend ils n'en font pas grand chose
en commun humiliant d'être qui je veux
faire un f3 je me demande pas l'idée
proposée le 3 non c'est évident 24
naturel marca ce sens le coup le coup
justin saric sodomie d'un dès la
première partie c'est vrai j'ai pu
refaire
l'idée viendrait mais il faudra bien
analyser après quoi à huy d'abrod mais
c'est quand il est chargé 5 du coup
franc je mets mes affaires tour c5
maintenant ouais c'est ça être
maintenant alors je sais pas ça bouge du
3 je pense ouais mais je ne sais pas
pourquoi il a voulu attendre la croûte
il va ya sûrement une idée si la russie
très longtemps et il ya un truc qui
m'échappe
atari sur b5 ouest en zinc ton pk
peut-être pour prend à 5 reprend
bessette et puis tu reviens b4 et
encaisse l'option de crème des chances
de nuls enfin c'est simple en plus
jeunes armés maï
voilà il réduit nombre d'options ouais
attend il veut peut-être même le
récupérer le pion f à la fin parce que
tout reprend tout reprendre tout reprend
tour f5
mais ça c'est sûr que c'est l'énorme
point fort d'abdou là c'est d'après ce
que m'a dit mur tu as pour faire ce
genre de choses il est vraiment très
fort pour défendre des trucs un peu
pas évident qu variable pourra de f5
peut-être torah de f 5 puis on prend f7
et sur b 5e importe quel coup elles cinq
poissons et s'y échangent des tours
c'est zéro chance pour la finale droit
donc de la france a plus et surtout
rares f5 tour f1 je joue à dix tours
et toi attend rien on qu'on regarde
peut-être f5 tour oeuvre des quatre
basso quand même le faire il faut pas
s'éloigner
ouais tu peux essayer peut-être celle là
mais bon patrice s'il est bien aussi les
pions avait été plus avancé tu vois la
vie de cinq ans selon la ba ouai tour f1
et francis roy huit ans avait passé
l'autre le truc que je calcule et mais
c'est fini tout de suite le faire les
montures en d4
tout ça ça se regarde même pas en
réalité donc est mauvais signe en fait
pour nous parce que dominés en fait et
quand il a fait revenir il aurait pu
planter plein de joueurs autres - force
au grand jour nous mais médard fait la
marche est trop haute
on va voir s'ils trouvent quand même
qu'ils tarnac un petit truc infâme ça
c'est qu'il est arabe et six tours prend
tour f53 et futurs un bon tour trois
marches aux siens non mais tu peux
prendre b2 du couturier faire en fait
ouais robes et si c'est fini
comment on va où il veut en venir mais
bon on joue si j'ouvre non mais gerso
comme d'hab il réfléchit beaucoup à il
veut en venir qu'il a coupé le roi je
peux dire ça va grand chose surtout v5
prouver qu'à ton fera twh trois soins
[Musique]
rex 3 c'est fini non cette fille samedi
8 encore tomber ton le chat le chat
gagner ouais ça va ça va être long un
fable si ça reste sur ce scénario là en
tout cas il a joué vraiment dans son
style caractéristique wesley so on a vu
les deux joueurs c'est vraiment au
contrôle ou glace contre glace j'aurais
dit c'est des champions glace non mais
ajuste y en un qui est un peu plus
glaçant que l'autre un peu plus froid
c'est ça mais sont quand même il est
parce qu il vient de faire en réalité
c'est vraiment dur tu en as l'impression
que la partie la gagner tout seul mais
ce qu'il a fait c'est vraiment très
difficile à faire
non le très bon je prends jamais le
faire ce sont des choix justes si je
mens c'est à ce parti se demander
pourquoi peut être quatre si vite c'est
parce que la fléche ici d'ailleurs une
peau de banane un truc je sais pas quoi
probablement et essaie d'être le plus
important à jouer en fait qui fait que
la galice facile mais qui fait que c'est
facile et qui fait que toi ou moi on
l'aurait perdu quoi on serait farhan haq
et puis après la finale tour était égal
nous l'aurait tourner une vraie fête
tombait un truc comme ça mais c'est pas
possible mais qui est nul il fait rien
oui bon il est nul à votre faim oui j'ai
objectivement pas non mais c'est sûr
mais tu vois il a un style qui ressemble
aussi un guillaume meyer pour parler un
peu la voir que les gens ont l'habitude
de voir sur internet
guillaume meyer il a exactement le même
style que sow et que abdou mais
peut-être qu'à son meilleur meilleur
était meilleur qu'eux
combien s'attend à un bon joueur n'est
encore judas koala 15 16 ans 17 ans à 16
ans non il sera plus fort que meyer ne
l'était à son meilleur niveau mais mais
je veux dire par là qu'un qu'un meilleur
à son meilleur niveau est plus fort
qu'un atout satarov aujourd'hui actuel
manuel ministre a pas meilleur que le
meilleur c'est ça très rarement sans la
comprendre et prendre la direction du
club pourquoi pas mais je sais pas j'ai
appris auprès de la dame prend du pion
passe je me dis que j'ai fixé des pions
un ouais mais peut-être qu'il veut non
mais ok ça je dois je voudrais si tu
veux faire des années même si je n'ai je
pas comme ça mais comme il n'a pas fait
ça va les pions avance alors du coup il
veut quoi il veut juste tour g1 et f5
tous sachent médecin cours de ces 5
propose des changes des dames mais ça
pour moi déjà faut calculer f5 dame
prend pions prends tu veux l'allier pour
le manger 5 ouais mais quand tu es
angers 5e je peux pas te faire hhf trop
je veux que je peux aller en déça et si
je mens 17 fait tourner mais qu'est ce
qui les force au tu vois ça c'est genre
de truc en fait tu joues étaient bloqués
lévitte way down g3 bien joué il
compterait 5 lui-même limite forcément
fait est ok mais faut calculer tous les
trucs à base de tours détient j'aurais
peur moi et les noirs quand même mais
bon
ouais non mais il ya un peu de jeu pour
les blancs mais effectivement ça peut
bien tourné ça peut très bien tourné
pour les noirs et celles à l'énorme
vraiment je veux tu vas mettre mettre un
point d'honneur à l'action l'accent est
sûre sur ce point fort de sauce et que
c'est un défenseur mais deux
folie quoi défenseur contraire ouais
c'est un genre de n'golo quand et non
non mais c'est un poumon 'non sur
l'échiquier est partout quoi il fera pas
de loin je la passe à deux mètres des
qui peut mais tu sais quand speech and
their deux saisons consécutives c'est
lui qui allait en finale contre contre
nac ah non mais les forains se faire que
sur ce format en fait normalement c'est
carlos est numéro un mondial hikaru
numéro deux et ce au numéro 3 gens
réellement en fallait résultats
attentats tendent à aller dans ce sens
là bas si tu fais 2 finales deux années
consécutives c'est que ça va quand même
dire beaucoup a le truc c'est pour les
formats parce que comme il ya beaucoup
de partis qui est très stable
il va te maintenir un niveau de jeu
constant qui fait pas vraiment rêver en
soi dans son style ou quoi mais votre
choix de chiens à battre il va jamais
trop se prendre deux pièges et ses
petites variantes sans risque sans
risque à un moment il t'épuises
peut-être même si de base c'est
peut-être plus fort ou tu domines un peu
arriver à maintenir un tel niveau après
pendant longtemps c'est pas facile il à
la stabilité puis du coup il peut plus
facilement et d'ailleurs dans la dans la
compétition sur sur cech 24 la batteur
cup
il était aussi allé en finale contre
magnus mais donc pas géré quand est
aussi stable pour être en finale tout le
temps partout ça c'est c'est fort quoi
c'est beau mais tu vas vlad m'avait dit
que c'était un des joueurs qui pensaient
pouvez gagner un jour les candidats ce
nom mais chez nous il est dithyrambique
un peu son sujet c'est un genre de
petrossian mais depuis les moins
dithyrambique là depuis un an j'ai
toujours dit qu'il ne réussirait jamais
fois j'ai toujours su non mais en fait
oui c'est ça il n'a que manque
d'ambition dans le jeu quoi
et que c'est pas un style en belang les
chiens à battre les avais j'avais lu une
interview de lui disais qu'en partie
longue il s'ennuyait en faites pas je
peux comprendre vu son style après mai
mais qui l'aimé pas qu'il y ait trop de
prépa trop de machin est en fait ça lui
plaît pas trop mais bon je connais bien
préparés aussi mais il est obligé
en fait tu peux pas y aller la fleur au
fusil dire oui j'aime pas ça oui ça ne
vole pas il est obligé de faire c'est
donc ce n'est pas un joueur d'élite et
puis c'est tout oui après tu peux faire
streamer lorsque tu veux mais tu es plus
aujourd'hui qu'à id4 écoute c'est pas
mal je préfère les noirs maintenant tu
vas fixer les pions tu vas mettre ton
cavagnan f5 qui va te blindés enfin non
je préfère les noirs j'abuse un peu mais
je sens que c'est en train de tourner je
mange pas des pleutres sur allan les
fuites mais peut-être il est en vie de
l'autre avancé de 5 ou point là je sais
pas j'aime paul moto club détour d un
des trucs comme ça alors atteint nougat
savent se jetait que l'époque et c'était
pourri caron le truc de streamer abbaoui
[Musique]
j'espère que tout le monde l'avait
compris quand même
bah pas vous que ça va être les autres
donc dame progressé de 7 pour ces huit
peut-être même demandé s'ils pouvaient
faire d'amd c'est ce que c'était ok bon
point c'est que mathias à tour sur un
septième c'est quand même pas si mal
mais de tuer quelqu'un croit les filtres
8 tu dis et le tour tassaout à roye f8
cavaliers histoire des huit mais aussi
j'avais vu ton j'ai vu les deux en fait
du coup je bon c'est pas mal web a
expliqué sea sax conçoit et autour des 8
et qu'elle et ses 5
vous démontrez bien un truc qui va
passer pour diriger la tour et tu veux
attaquer f4 au passage donc mais tu n'es
tu te retrouves mieux nancy tu stabilise
avec les noirs parce que la structure
blanche et enfin ils sont pas liés ils
sont solides quand même eu le temps non
mais tu as raison
bah le problème de ces structures de
pions noirs c'est pas qu'ils soient
faibles c'est juste que tu fais pas
toujours passé normalement c'est un
quatre contre trois qui
une telle majorité qui marche pas mais
lui cleveland c'est encore pire
le roi des deux voilà je t'annonce qui
veut faire un roi et fuit tour 17
cavaliers 6 3 3 et se préparer pour la
finale qui avait des f-5 ouais donc il
fait bon plan du coup comme comme
l'autre a fait ça il fait ça il va faire
le roi 8 du coup il est et ouest avait
les deux idées quoi ce qui t'arrange les
cavaliers souvent tu as beaucoup de
route pour eux donc preuve faut choisir
celle qui t'arrange jamais regarder
entre 2,10 je t'annonce une victoire de
saut non mais il est mieux la main ça
c'est sûr faut juste pas prendre tu leur
mets pas bien les pions noirs très bien
gardé son roi ramener sa tour ans je
veux faire c'est cinq jours puis petit à
petit
well as rome 7 tours fc les deux
prochains coulant bref c'est à tours
enfin j'ai du mal à dire oui vedettes
sont bons ces cinq d'abord pourquoi pas
il peut avoir wade c3 c6 aussi ouais
c'est souvent dans les cinq à quatre
tours troyes habitat oui mais il en a
partout quoi c'était arrivé en fait son
fouillis de votre choix quoi et kf5 et
des quatre noms ouais c'était son idée
ça depuis tout à l'heure avec le fiancé
cinq sets et sur petit frenchy h61
moment pour pote claude gênât rouge et
5e s'il souffle je sais pas quoi non
mais il ya beaucoup cédé face à levon
problème il va apprendre et les quatre
prochains tours b un tour je sais pas ou
feint haye peu trop évident et il peut
avoir des cahiers des quatre tours à
deux pour mater aussi à huy tour et
surtour d2 qui a eu deux cavaliers f4
terrible c'est fini monsieur boostore
ouais il va falloir qu'ils aillent qui
joue plus vite un petit peu comme un
abdoujaparov oui la vie au sprint
traille est super fort c'était pris la
grosse cannes est une fois sur sur les
champs oui
alors du coup il va faire il va faire
pas tour g1 tour j'ai quand tu finisses
à s'échapper mais peut-être que tout
retour d un petit coup de contrôle après
tu peux aussi faire des c6 b5 parfois ça
peut être l'idée d'accords branche
empêchera je cherche aussi à des coûts
puisque par essence même il est sain qui
défend bien l'instant il craque pas été
baisse je dois te faire b4 s'est passé
des faiblesses et les changes auraient
bien gardé la tour mais ok il a bien
réfléchi avant de faire ça non mais il
défend à tous et les 4èmes en bien ça va
gagner un pion ce 7 kg 3 bien des photos
ou alors il prend et voûtes
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ne font bien quand
même à souligner l à la défense elle est
fantastique des noirs des blancs avec si
peu de temps comment tu fais ça ces cinq
teintes noir auront à c 3 je pense est
nul est ce que on peut pas les prendre
m5 ou g7 et puis 4 août une autre pari
qu'ont ces personnes qui arrivent eux
car il est 5 h quatre cavalières 3-6 6-1
et des quatre tours peut-être qu'ils
étaient cinq déclare ainsi vu de ce qui
est des 3 1 on y monte et m'a menacée
compliqué face à l'euro à 6,3 ici non
armée énorme défense de dap doit
vraiment franchement chapeau 1
il va sûrement la perdre et tout et tout
mais quand même a souligné quoi c est
maintenant régis h 6ème et attend son
roi maintenir passe ici note 2 nuls eva
cavalli lecavalier 4c sa nouvelle 2,5
ouais qu'avaient les dessins croit 17,4
ces six mois c'est cette recette au pied
de très droit et fuite n'aura 17 le
retour à leopard server accède potter ou
vous lancer cet apparent 6,7 alors
attends maintenant faut faire voilà je
veux dire kvh celui-ci convoyage 5 le
pion il pousse pousse et cavaliers h5 et
prend m6 h3 énormément t'arrête pas les
deux badawi soin ses distances et les
fins et 4 et le parvenir il veut faire
car il sait de six études et vie parce
qu'ils avaient des écoutes cas la taille
de loin ça suffit 3 mais impressionnant
ouest vient ce que tu as et sur pareil
c'est son style pas virevoltant mais
c'est un peu ainsi lara petrossian dans
l'esprit écrase au titre non mais là en
fait il a bien gagné
ouais mais tu vois c'est un il a jamais
il s'emballe pas quand ils cherchent
jamais le killing l'eau ou quoi il
cherche jamais à tuer en fait ils
cherchent à gagner s'en prend sans
jamais prendre le moindre risque
c'est ça facile là il va le prendre en
fait il est content dresse à +0 8 +0 9
pendant 60 coups et un moment donné tu
vas faire une faute et je partais je
suis d'accord avec lui on serait tous
contents de s'en aller c'est vraiment un
homme un orfèvre pour pour faire savoir
qu'il prendrait quatre c'est jouable
c'est juste que ce qu'est une pièce un
peu la regagner puis on prend fou prend
des 5 et j'essaie dans ses pions les
secouristes comme ça des fois dans les
françaises mais là bon prince qui l'a
peut-être atterrir en c5 juste pour
illustrer un ce que tu dis sous des deux
comme ça
illustration fait on est content si on a
foutu quai en b2 était loin de tous les
bugs et en tue plus tard en tout cas les
blancs sont gênés là comme ça c'est à
peu près bouclé au 15 mai si la pac les
pros mais qu'at-il et pas juste mal
parce qu'il va se faire fermer l'allèle
dames et ça va être la france est
évoquée mais c'est française uta passé
le fou devant à le jouer et il veut
faire pousser de hook est ici de hockey
menaces poussé d'offres prend 1,4
peut-être fou des deux alarmes non 6
pourquoi pas t2 savanes ont bien sûr à
mes surfaces états unis fait comment
n'ai-je étant petit problème ou pas bob
statut fait donne un [ __ ] con tu
déroule ce soir à madrid et jordan c'est
un homme prend 2 points 4 août il faut
qu'on vous prend 1,4 j'aurai un coin
courage mesdames points à 4/4 fait chier
si tu te prends deux échecs sont tombés
quatre chaque fois est ce qu'il n'ya pas
un coup ici je le trouve pas ok donc ça
tu peux pas un métier que ça gagne
peut-être son truc bon elle et ses trois
qui a essayé de le roi des deux epr en
inde amoureux ok mais tu en as toujours
un peu de joueurs des sags beckham soit
pas mais avant il va faire à trois tours
b1 et il va essayer de jouer un peu
comme dans des bennes co je sais pas si
on peut appeler ça un même comme ea je
préfère les noirs là non bon au mieux
dimanche que ça donne oui on je pense
c'est plutôt ce que j'écris non ça peut
jouer autant prêt j'allais l'épouser
thion est ce qu'il arrive à clôturer le
truc ou pas ce que b5 direct tu prends
pas la tour tu attends je vous assure à
3 pts tu peux prendre
épreuve 1 2 me prends un b 5 à 3 des
blancs ils ont l'air d'être puis
d'attendre et de et caillage cadre
d'échangés de fou sinon on tombe bien
faire des trucs alors qu'ils soient à
temps et pour te taper à b5 même enfin
peut-être pas le gagner mais en tout cas
pour complètement bloquée et venir à
préfère food et de fougue et 4 un jour
est défoncé dans neuf casa barilla prix
prix ok mais bah alors on va voir
comment il se débrouille des pavés 5
si tu arrives à faire des quatre
peut-être pas obligé de faire des cinq
six ou quoi claquettes je ferais bien
que des lois c'est de ce choix f5 qui
fait chier bref je pense sur un tempo
cavaillac h4 pour un tour bien où tu
commences par dame b2b dame b 5 échecs
est ce que t'es pas content des changes
et les dames mettent leur en c3 il suit
notre première intuition
ouais c'est vrai cette ce fou pour voir
la tour qui vivent bien ça sonne pas
souhaité 5 il est pénible
il empêche de prendre la colonne ouvert
qui est bien placée de soutenir les
pions ce qu'ils avancent ou qui est un
très fort pièces donc l'échangé c'est
quand même c'est la meilleure pièce
noire avec la dame
oui je vous fais tu ne peux pas laisser
fois je sais tu vas faire cavalier prend
hélas le seul truc un peu pénible c'est
qu'on va perdre ce fou production
probablement dette mais cette date est
ce pas prendre part à un faux calcul et
mais des fois tu prends elsa retour b8
ça t'ouvre un peu de dembé deux fois les
poteaux qui font leurs droits c'est 2 en
fait on colmate how dame b de direct
j'avais pas vu comme ça je pensais
qu'ils allaient échanger faire ou à ces
deux j'arrive il bloque toutes les
quatre mesdames b2 non mais peut-être
qu'il a juste donné un peu le pion b
pour prêt pour s'activer
mais chez pas on peut finir enfin pas
trop calculé qu'au si oui ce dont je
vais rentrer dans soho plus loin un pion
évoquer mon regard des cipayes prendre
hélas il est noir on pas de jeu ça va
être
à très difficile à jouer parce que tu as
plus qu'un pion t'a plu plus que pions
tour contre les deux pièces sauf que la
position assez fermé et peut-être tenter
des trucs ça j'aime pas qu'on s'a
marcher pour prouver sa tête six fois
c'est de faire de saint caprais et des
trucs mais mais j'y crois pas damon a le
fou qui va revenir ans ces deux il va
clôturer cette aile là et ça peut faire
3 rbd 4 mai poussé deux hommes trois
mais quatre qui prend des 5
il fait dans ce sens là on peut refuser
l'échangé de factures même si tu rentres
quand bien même tu rentreras en b2 en
fait fait pas grand chose un nom
même si le perturber ville probablement
mais surtout après les blancs pour
trouver un truc à faire
c'est pas évident à pour personne ce que
tu fais pas tu as aimé damas car en fait
une menace pas d âge peut faire dame 1 4
à 3 peut-être si j'avais envie d'essayer
de faire cavalier à 4 kgs c'est vrai
mais bon on voit jamais arriver et je
pense ça peut faire nul en fait par un
manque de plans mutuelle constructif a
par contre échanger les dames c'est
plutôt une réussite pour les blancs non
cavalli ac à 3 c3 jeu bon après on dit
en général que la tour elle se
débrouille bien content de pièces mais
là il ya quand même des idées pour les
blancs laqués laquelle j'aime bien qu'à
3 c3 quelques îlots revenir vers ses
cinq concédés attaquer un peu à 500 fait
l'ena je considérerais ferenczi souvient
notre colonne pour la tour notre côté
mais qui et c'est ça qui est chiant et
de taille que six américaine c'est un
peu glauque ados kg 5e jouera bien même
moment un prix moyen de dire n est pas
bien évolué qu'à se structure soit il
prend il aura ses quatre faibles
toujours soit il proposera des 5 qui
sera faible et la roi ces trois rois
prend ces quatre états pas de casque
d'entrée tu as une colonne ouverte mais
l'école maths et par les pièces bien sûr
vous faut des pions un parent et surtour
b4 et c3 pour
où ces deux touchés à weepu ses deux
plus forts parade enfin bien joué ça tu
bloques heroes ac3 penser qu'après si tu
perds ces cas tu penses la partie est
quasi perdu mais je crois qu'il va faire
un pas je sais pas trop comment il
compte ne pas le perdre ça me fait
penser au film d'eric judor problème au
statu quo non face à na v non mais c'est
pas un super film est en fait pendant
tout le film n'a que des petits
problèmes khwaja chaque foyer problème
hausse
c'est super congrès bah oui vapeur
évacués mais deux qui en france et 4 à
qui va être en l'air c'est une master
class en fait mais en fait c'est ça
c'est que des portes pédagogique plus
long que alors à temps et encore il
valait à l'époque ce qu'est ce que c'est
bien joué il lui coupe la cinquième qui
valurent à le faire moi nous revoilà
non mais il est insupportable à 4 pro b
3 3 mais c'est mieux à deux tours 1 1 il
se démène à fond mais ça suffit pas à
quoi je te préviens on réussir est
vraiment pas à prendre une partie abdou
en fait s'il défend trop bien le les
valeurs vertes ans dugas et un pétard ou
4 et h3 ayant plus rien a attaqué puis
petit à petit va être attaqué les pieds
au roi ck3 bessin et vous qui avez 7
machin je suis arrivé non mais c'est
impressionnant le défend tous ses pions
faible mais wave 3 3 ils veulent faire
un moment tu as on notera pillage de m
puis c'est tout voir h 4 h 5 tant qu'à
faire comme sa tâche si ça peut fixer à
jour le cavaly pour révolter le prendre
il veut faire aux 5 ou plus parce que
ces plantes et des 3b de calculer si ce
troc h contre à 5 mais je pense pas mais
ils commencent par kébé sais tu vas
faire h3 maintenant je pense roi b6 et
je vois bien faire un genre de cavale et
des huit cavaliers ici alan tu as marqué
ces quatre ils vont envoyer les pions
c'est trop fort en fait ouais ce n'est
pas tant la tour là-bas où c'est pas
trop mal même ce qui va faire kébé 3 du
coût sûrement pour que vous avez pas de
tour un tout petit tour des options
alors battu phoenix ya je vois encore au
c3 il l'a fait du non mais je me demande
s'il faisait pas mieux de garder h et
navigue avec le carré de l'autre côté
chez patch pas pu calcul j'ai
l'impression que tu gagnes et le pion h
en force
en fait j'ai l'impression que c'était
mieux de troquer à 4 contre h5 au cas où
pour envoyer j'ai un enfant que c'était
plus fort d'envoyer pions h pour les
blancs mais bon c'est un traître c'est
gagnant juste un bon bah c'est sûrement
mon retour gagnons rien à faire il va
lui coûter le roi entre fois çi ce
faible et d'un pion à défendre c'est
trop il va lui faire quoi les faits
racistes ou b cette brève ailleurs
[ __ ] cavagnan cette date exacte donc
ça ne peut faire à 6 à 7 à 8 et apple
rock in school est insupportable non je
sais pas qui est ce cas pourquoi y
réfléchit my fait peut-être un petit
al-ram dit aller retour quel [ __ ]
petit coup de fouet ses biens relève ce
qu'assure à 6 3 6 3
si l'aca pas fou c'est 6 mai foyen
attention c'est bien joué quand même ce
qui fait d'envoyer enfants contre je le
fais toi ils sont fous notre caillou 5
finalement à et maintenant il va te
refais et leur voix dans re4 changement
d'avis toutes les versions tc4 il va le
faire qu'à idée de maintenant ouais j'ai
failli te laisses f3 uk et des deux rois
des trois rouges et le fou plus fous 2
je pense wave ailleurs faire food vient
un jour le roi à fuji qu'yat-il vient
toucher là maintenant aborder cette
fourchette problème alors mais c'est
impressionnant et en plus le roi est
super mal placé il ya food et 5 fprov 3
c'est terrible ce qui vient de lui faire
or il est impressionnant brad et moi ce
match face à lyon ce sera la même chose
tant pis mais qu'est-ce qui les forme on
fab
franchement ça m'impressionne des partis
comme ça c'est pas toi satin pression'
ou pas bah oui et non enfin en fait
[Musique]
casser qui joue bien avec peu de temps
la pendule peu près c'est faisable c'est
faisable non mais jamais les scouts le
piège il fait tout bien s'agir nous on a
un trial part évidemment ou quoi mais en
fait on n'arrive pas quand on n'arrive
pas avec aussi peu de temps c'est ça
serait que de jamais gaffé jamais laissé
le contre je l'appuie ton fils à de la
petite merde tout ça il prend les bonnes
décisions assez vite troqué à contre h
c'était bien et c'est pas décision
facile à prendre
donc c'est bien ce que x non franchement
franchement tu vois ces genres de parti
tu peux vraiment les données en cours
quoi c'est c'est un cours là qui lui
donne ses partie pédagogique sur
portefeuille a été nul je ne veux pas
jouer contre toi il ya déjà 3 0 est à
l'impression que ce au ca écossaise
ouais il attendait de truquer cash 4
maintenant tout ça il fait ça ayachi 4è
je me suis seul en plein de couilles à 5
mesdames mais c'est marrant ce que ça va
pas du tout dans son style quoi
changement de changement de programme de
le site
j'ai l'idée c'est de sortir le fouet
fuite en fait est un chemin juste pour
dire un johnny d'art qui écrit un
rouleau compresseur qui avance
inexorablement c'est vraiment
l'impression que ça donne aux 96 saut
c'est ce qui se fait de mieux au niveau
stratégique au monde le titre de 960 qui
ne l'a pas volée en mai bon car c'est là
que je veux l'oublier quand on sait ce
que c'est ce qui se fait de lui le monde
sur un domaine non mes sauts c'est très
bien c'est très compact parce qu'il fait
annoncer ce que fait faut pas oublier il
calcule très bien son ouais c'est quand
c'est bon bein défense de ses joueurs à
très haut niveau en fait parce que bon
ben là tu vois enfin stratégie pas
stratégie la tp sont recomposées enfin
montré calcul quant à là c'est que du
cpt afin que du calcul c'est presque que
du calcul mais ok au moins sept trois
filles tentent de changer un peu quelque
chose il a raison pour faire un truc
compliqué un peu plus un peu plus chou
comme position très molle qui me dit
finalement maxime est peut-être dans la
bonne partie de tableau alors il va
avoir un match hyper difficile en quarts
contre artemiev artemiev ccp aussi un
c'est très épais un an blitz sur
internet enfin même en longues cp mais
c'est très très épais artemiev ça va
être compliqué bon pour être est ce une
belle compétition en termes de plateau
ce satané ya un beau plateau sont je
crois pas que tu es vraiment un côté du
tableau simples allant ses partenaires
c'est dur de partout c'est vrai que
c'est n'est pas ils ont changé le
non c'est peut-être mieux ils ont
maintenant ils ont changé le tableau
artémias ses comptes carlson exactement
écoute c'est mieux bagéens et pau j'ai
pas trop par un peu je l'aimais style
mais que je pense maxime où les mieux
c'est
ouais je pense que l'epo est bien
meilleur dans le match up en match up
contre maxime je pense que tu es quand
même beaucoup plus d'un kg et contre
artémias fin c'est un grand mot inquiet
mais oui enfin bon marché mais je
pensais à 50 50 parce qu artemiev s'il
te joue ce truc c'est double fiant kétou
ces machins et il est vraiment pénible
alors que nepos ça va être un match à
est hyper tactique ou quoi sauf qu'une
épaule peut-il tu es et maxime il peut
lui faire très très mal à un moment
donné je pense que maxime il a un petit
à petit avantage psychologique
ban est posée quand même qu'il a bien
bien réussi dans sa carrière
mardi soir il ya eu ce truc à jérusalem
mais à part ça en fait c'est tout est ce
que j'irai une chance contre artemiev je
pense que guy arriva juste se faire
dézinguer comportait bien et pour moi il
dit rien feytiat se faire défoncer ça va
être impressionnant mais pose sur un bon
jour il démonte tout le monde où il se
fait démonter l'om et je pense justement
contre maxime il peut te savoir le petit
ça va d'avant-match quoi était d'être en
mode arrêt joue encore maxime fait chier
tu vois mais bien sûr des pouilles votre
maxime sait pas mais qu'en fait ce sera
tout un match où maxime serait plutôt
favoris quand même je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi c'est que jérusalem
bas c'était le dernier grand prix
qu'elles pratiquent pour les candidats
comptent 1 51 pendant et sanofi et cette
année finale est en fait le gars qui
gagnait ce match et se qualifier pour
les quarts d'heure par avoir des
bouffées la finale mais et maxime est
perdu en demie voilà donc là c'était
c'est pas un bon souvenir mais sinon à
part ça c'est seule défaite en
particulier de contenus qu une des
seules deux sévi en tout cas sinon il a
un très bon score dans le raid up est
d'ailleurs un bon candidat il a abattu
sa dernière ronde avant l'arrêt du
tournoi sur la sur la win over
il a bien battu en plus un smatch est
quoi ouais s'avérera cucquois son maxi
noah sait tous à des photos des styles
qui devront bien mieux que d'autres
doivent être gérés qu'ils ont surtout le
même style et maxime est juste un peu
plus fort quoi ça on va dire que les
points forts de maxime vu leur même s'il
est plus forte que peut-être que né peau
du cou va mieux réussir contre d'autres
joueurs mais oui vrai qu'on tenait pour
le problème d'arreau nian c'est qu' il
n'est pas plus fort en blitz est en
rapide par contre en bullet il va
prendre cher les vannes je pense ouais
bah oui c'est ça qui est toujours c'est
quoi elle n'était pas très rapide à
venir les autres années quand on voyage
où il était vraiment beaucoup moins fort
que les autres en bullet à moins qu'ils
aient progressé qui se sont entraînés
sinon ouais mais à huit est plutôt
content et oui et donc c'est carlson
artemiev du coup qui pourrait être un
quart de finale assez sympa fait
d'offrir ses jokers effets de seuil f je
crois qu'ils jouent n'a qu'à me disais
comme les tables ont changé en fait je
me suis mélangé nouveaux tableaux et
l'ancien s'était si bien que ça ce match
de feydeau c'est contre vous terminèrent
vraiment vraiment extraordinaires mais
voilà que j'ai vu que ça faisait un peu
autour ben écoute ça a fini à
à égalité après 3h30 et quatre parties
de départager le match était hyper chaud
en fait ils se rendaient coup pour coup
et c'était l'inversé du match
d'aujourd'hui c'est un peu comme cette
partie là c'était tout le temps tactique
à fond mais il était super fort les deux
fait je voyais pas fait de l'ocf aussi
fort alors que maxime avait prévenu il
avait dit fait d'os très fort alors on a
vu un pareil c'est un match de vous
faire mais en fait c'est le truc c'est
pour ça que oui le format est pas mal
mais faut que les matches sont
équilibrés mais sa troupe à prévoir à
l'avancé mais du coup faut que les
matches qu'ils soient pas ils soient pas
équilibrée puisse se finir vite ces gens
là un point d'écart sous le baby plupart
ouais il faut récréer une limite en fait
ailleurs raffarin qui est un moment à
huit points c'est bien on est à huit
points tu arrêtes peut-être même si
point jeu mais oui disent non et pose un
défi nition montparnasse faire certes
souhaitable artemiev fort aussi tombé de
challenges suis pas d'accord n'est poney
peau est un bien meilleur adversaire
pour maxime carte n y avait pas si
maxime et dans le chat ça m'étonnerait
mai
mais je pense qu'il sera d'accord là
dessus ou un petit baky ambulants tu
vois maxime il n'est pas dans le chatt
rabbin après dépôt tête j'avais d'abris
qui sont super forts qu'il sorte un gros
truc c'est au fait qu'ils marchent par '
mais mettra en jeu comment quatre heures
d'affilée c'est pas évident non plus
d'un puits à retenir qu il est tout le
temps là les title tuesday il est là la
compet l'autre jour encore c'était quoi
c'était le super saturday chez pas quoi
il était encore bien classés facture il
est toujours là en fait c'est un mec
stable aussi comme souvent ouais ouais
moi je le trouve vraiment for heart emi
a fait tuer on en discutait dans ce
style là je sais plus avec qui c'était
mais sur le fait qu'il n'a jamais eu sa
chance à haut niveau alors qu'il était
9e 11e mondial c'était vrai concept avec
moins de temps pour le faire je le
connais pas mais tu vois j'étais pas
j'étais déçu pour lui honoré parce que
quand j'étais à l'année où la gagne à
gibraltar haut la main et hockey
gibraltar c'est vraiment dur de gagner
j'ai pas trop souvient de mcgill en
solitaire gibraltar très souvent ça se
fait dans des partages et lui il avait
des consultants d'un bon petit à faire
nul même scène puisque sur f 4k
réussissent mais bon il a peut être
d'être au meilleur de guérison plus que
meiway artemiev c'était c'était une
sacrée performance avec pas vraiment
d'ouverture du machin carreaux kf3 g3
qui fêtera ses 4 titres et y est tu
sentais qu en terme de niveau de jeu au
poste c'était costaud mais s'il ya déjà
trois ans je tire à cette histoire est
depuis toujours n'a jamais trop vu
il a fait un petit fils cadet ou quoi
mais ouais il appelle des prix dans les
andes gestour des choses comme ça mais
c'est dommage
et depuis ben du coup je suis pas si les
tympans rachou si ça va un peu démotivés
ou quoi il a un peu peur de vélo depuis
mais l'om je pense qu'ils auraient
mérité sa chance au moins en quelques
tours à de l'élite ont été largement
largement parce que firoud déjà à ce que
toutes à des joueurs comme ça mais alors
qu'est ce qui va me forget plus légitime
voilà ils sont pas plus légitime que je
plante et même une ligne entre toujours
avancer l'histoire de là je vais voir
tout méfait que vincent là il était chez
lui c'était 9e au 11e mondial mais à 60
ouais puis avec un style avec un style
agréable quand même
alors là faut jouer des cinq équipes
quatre choix là ne disait que ses
joueurs qu'ils auraient qui lui a
rappelé le plus car le sel artemiev oui
peut-on encore une partie de haut vol
je suis donné que ce soit entré dedans
bref de s'amuser un pas le genre de la
maison
non tu as tu veux faire comme le chat
qui attrape la souris que ça peut jouer
avec des petits coups de patte et weeds
on est à 45 minutes de jeu soit il reste
il restait encore trois heures quoi
c'est encore trois heures il ya que
trois points et le pour répondre le plus
gros écart de ce fichage pas que c'était
si points mais c'était maxime contre eux
oui quand un favori net de 3 4 points je
crois que c'est jamais arrivé qu'ils se
fassent qu'ils se fassent remonter ils
ont pas eu beaucoup plus de chance pour
l'instant duda fille ruth chaâba aussi
vous avez chirurgien c'est le tournant
car tu aimais afin faut arrêter non mais
les genres artemiev ils n'ont même pas
qualifiés pour les grands prix fidh
oui c'est quand même fou quoi enfin
moment non mais même double affirmation
qu'il est plus d'invitation coeur là des
boeufs beaucoup plus avec son chrono si
j'adhère 80 points
ouais mais il est moscovite et voilà on
avait déjà parlé de ça joue les
relations le relationnel côté un peu
politique et tout ça ça joue baird
coiffer des émissions youtube pour la
fidh et ses feintes eu assez
c'est important c'est un peu comme en
formule 1 tu vas falloir les bons les
bons bacs est quoi c2 c3 que les façades
c'est ce que je veux questionné sur la
position
bon écoute c'est compliqué mais je crois
qu'il marquait sa pièce même mais est ce
que c'était de forcer nhk bairi
d'affilée une pièce vide à deux pions
dont probablement je passais à cuire et
kébé 7 tous à cette marche de la tête a
été lente voire en mai c'est intéressant
je sais pas comment ils vont jouer a
fait l'ouverture
d'habitude les noirs ils arrivent à
faire qui est des cinq qui avait quatre
qui prend des trois mais après je sais
pas leur rentrer dedans juste ou le très
très vite et moi je joue sa gnac les
blendecques les landes
donc m quoique india 9e et karoui à
l'heure actuelle une offre des carmes
est double
on entend les témoins de 2007 il ya eu
des fuites et 27 60 alors accroché des
pierres tombées à 2007 sont 10 15 20 mai
wlan mais c'est déjà fini en fait j'ai
toujours dit ce ne sera jamais plus à 27
81 non mais maintenant il a des gamins
en plus déjà et tout fin c'est vraiment
fini je crois quinito olemps ouais bah
oui problemas le nom pour pour l'aider
grâce à ben je te confirme ouais je te
confirme qui va prendre le tarif abdou
bâ est déjà père d'un responsable soit
il a changé d'ouverture êtes une petite
prépa qui l'a fait qu'ils passent pas
contre un mec du top s'est dit je vais à
passer là il a dit ça et voilà
mais ok qui aimait cet échec au roi mais
c'était soit je suis tu te rends fou b2c
carnage 5.5 thème m'as tu vu beaucoup et
ça paye c'est un beau dead mais pas du
coup tu fermes ta brandon ouais j'suis
pas à ça la suivante une date pour lui
tous les joueurs sont finies et ne
feront jamais rien après saint claude
dans ce qui menace d'être champion du
monde y en a pas beaucoup quoi
fondamentalement détour des vite
alors comment il voit cloué tout ça si
les cahiers des deux kébé 3 way est ce
que hacker la transpac consacré sur
l'autre tour en d1 aussi en plus donc et
il n'y avait ici et qu'ils avaient trois
ça a l'air bien ouais bon cette rue que
j'aurais vu enfin que j'avais dis bien
sélectivement je passais mieux que
l'autre kébé cette tour a vite ou s'il
se joue pas là cinq bien tenté voulons
pas suffisant mais bien tenté pour
déranger un peu surpris on prend notre
handicap je pense c'est ce que je me
disais aux plus âgés étaient des
caillots 6 à la fin tel carnage c'est un
carnage les amis ça à faire + 4 1 moi
j'avais donné un pour cent de chance à
douchez tête était généreux
maxime avait donné sept il avait été
très généreux enfin l'avait donnée 0
j'ai tout gâché peut-être sévère aussi
pour l'instant ce que je vois ça donne
raison
ouais c'est un carnage un aboiement
quelqu'un va lui aussi se fout c'est
cadré mais enfin je crois pas que ce
soit un truc qu'il ait manqué en fait
c'est toute la position qu'ils allaient
pas façon décrite par tous j ai quand
même deux pions pour la pièce donc c'est
pas tout à fait suffisant en termes
matériels plus on n'était pas loin et
voilà ça va être sa qualité de moitié
les plus saints du perso si ce peut être
un cheval sous là pour réfléchir à ce
qu'on vous jette sur ces 6 ou pas ne pas
trop afficher une tendresse et vous
verrez c'est la 30e et la défense
l'autoroute vers nice je suis du genre
qui d'après leur dis c'était ok oui mais
peut-être avait un truc forcé de je sais
pas quoi à trouver à jouer mais tu vas
jamais le trouver
non mais ok dans le loser tour du monde
ne doit pas c'est qu'elle sait pas trop
à gauche que nature sa poitrine offensif
je peux dire qu'abdou à la caméra je
sais que je sais que tu vois pas les
câbles mais il tombe de sa chaise non
mais ça se voit qu'il en a déjà marre en
fait ah bah oui mais ça va c'est le même
scénario que par am en fait tu l'aies
défonce pendant une heure une heure et
demie mais au bout d'un moment
bon après c'est pour être bien sûr je
comprends mais même pour sow en fait
c'est relou par là tu mènes déjà quatre
points tu le défonce et que le match
soit en deux sets gagnants si partie
gagne 6,2 et puis c'est fini enfin on
n'en parle plus quoi
là on va d'infliger de jouer pour
qu'israël c'est le bien meilleur format
de tous
non mais c'est moi c'est pour les
joueurs aussi que je trouve ça un peu
gênant quoi ouais mais ces femmes on
serait dans le même cas fab franchement
de celui qui se fait défoncer c'est
vraiment pas agréable tu vois imagine
baky comme ça pendant 3h30 moi je viens
même pas en fait
baky je lui dis non baky l'afp bravo si
tu veux baky la photo ça dépend encore
été payés en fait en soi c'est gratuit
aucun intérêt à se faire défoncer pendez
a trop des coups sur la tête mais ça me
fait penser à un match de boxe ou t k o
10 secondes par terre non relève toi ne
s'acharne sur la gueule encore trop
taper sur la gueule pour être bien bien
sûr ça serait beau quoi que ça finisse
comme dans snatch quoi qu'en fait il le
défonce après quoi tu fais jouer un
gitan quoi comme dans ce match quand ils
et défonce tout ça après quoi prend six
points d'avancé comme asie quoi mr
fantastique ce film stack sa superficie
mais il ya l'autre qui est très bien
dans le même style arnaques crimes et
botanique hd jamais vu on dirait parler
c'est guy ritchie donc qui a fait les
deux et non très bien pas c'est pas
mieux que ce match c'était vraiment une
super référence mais l'autre est
vraiment bien aussi et c'est même aimé
l'esprit quoi c'est marrant c'est bien
s'écoute c'était un vieux sage témoin
l'autre c'est sur ça que la faim en plus
c'est génial
géré par là que des fois des films qui
sont bien tout le long et la fin est
décevante et la sna qui en fait tout est
très bien notre guise
j'avoue et ce qu'ils peuvent non ils
n'ont pas le droit d'abandonner dons qui
sont ils sont vraiment obligés de se
faire défoncer pendant quatre heures
seul nom mais je suis désolé en fait ça
me rend triste pour les fins ça me rend
triste pour le joueur aussi quoi je ne
veux pas j'y peux rien en fait je
compatis 10 devrait pouvoir in fine le
match à +6 d'écart ouais je pense qu'il
devrait pouvoir in fine un moment donné
si tu as envie vrai nom mais tant que tu
y crois tu peux te battre mais à un
moment tu sais que je peux plus non mais
là par exemple encore te dire allez je
m'accroche peut-être qu'en trois minutes
j'aurais une chance et si tu couvres ces
trois mines par trois défaites encore là
ok toujours adroit de hockey c'est fini
tu perds
non mais la part par exemple
n'abandonnerai pas encore sur un match
aussi mon nom je continuerai à jouer en
fait mais si ça continue un peu comme ça
oui
bon là ça a l'air d'être complètement
égal 1 ouais ouais ça va je sais pas qui
est vraiment mieux si je peux dire
quelqu'un mieux c'est sensé plus ou
moins égales mais des micros différence
et peut-être même un peu mieux les noirs
j'espère ainsi cessé troqué sa là-bas et
oui pas tu peux mais c'est pas
entièrement train fait en gros b4 et
resterai un peu plus faible que ces six
à sept pour vraiment pas davantage ou
chance d'un oui oui c'est ok je
comprends tu veux dire c'est juste si tu
choisi une couleur tu prends salam était
pas bien sûr qua non
fabien croze cette position pendant
quatre heures pour beaucoup ça je
n'empêche ce qui est bien avec ce truc
là c'est que ça nous a fait gagner le
l'expression bien sûr exactement c'est
avant on n'était pas forcément bien sûr
ce qu'il veut faire g5 bizarrerie simple
écoute je vais céder fait un truc sur g7
petit tour au g15 ses idées des blancs
les cinq voix bien pas bien joué ça la
manif mais je pense que si on prend qui
a aidé 4 et sur 5 2 500 tonnes sont
s'est fixé en fait thomas sculpteur 1 km
pour arriver tour g1 torje 6 mais oui
vous avez bien joué ça que j'aime bien
celle boukouss élégant inattendu mais en
fait hyper logique vu que on comprend
que la messe des gens se diraient cinq
viols dont gaza bien je aussi problème
hausse ça a étrillé pour les blancs fait
parce que tu vas pouvoir faire un f6
tout reproche 5 ça tu peux pourquoi les
jeunes filles eux pour cette foire aux
cinq sens je pense mais pourquoi pas
mais il faut qu'ils la gagnent salade ou
j'ai l'impression qu'il a un peu baissé
de régime
ouais notre ami wesley a laissé
l'occasion de frapper non mais ça ferait
plaisir pour lui la d'heure dans le body
lent dans le langage corporel par dont
il est un peu mieux il sait d'eux c'est
la question c'est ça
je pense qu'ils la gagnent en tours 7e
reprend g7 qui part en retour de sa
tenue ouais ça je veux me reste deux
finales mais on attend autour des 740
qu'un pourrait certes encore en quarts
et medal tuons pas s'éloigner de cette
quelque chose il dit que d'ailleurs il
ne l'a pas fait et tour g7 il veut faire
quoi de tours à 3 tours g5 ses cinq
coupes et essayer de faire de la caf
contre contre rennes je pense que ça
doit être nul précis jamais si simple à
faire enfin bon pour lustrer très simple
mais c'est objectivement nul
détrompe-toi fade lice pour le garder
ouais mais bon je viens de perdre un
jour suivant ouais mais comment tu es 3
7 6 6 3 6 donc je ratais ces cas
possibles à gagner ça pour l'évent faut
être sérieux il fermera ses trois mêmes
en fait très fin foreman roanne en
vrille mais je sois tu parles où les
côtés je t'ouvre changer sa couche en
tout cas c'est bien si jamais il a gagné
bon c'est encore enfin ces gagnants mais
je sais pas si encore moins quand même
de faire de la mairie
je pensais mieux tous cf que h parce que
la torah la planète pour h3 ce que je
pensais aussi est ce qui peut tenter un
truc de fou in lorsque 3 il a pris comme
ça où tout est fini tout de suite et la
gaffe et je me demandais ce qu'il avait
en tête
bon ben ok première victoire c'est bien
pour lui parler c'est cool ça fait
plaisir mais ça change un petit truc et
wesley qui rêvait de passer partie
d'avant qui jouent des quatre même pas
un peu du match
les petits gambie dame classique
orthodoxe alors attends il reste combien
de partis en 5 + 1 il reste fab 28
minutes
c'est quoi c'est plus ou moins trois
parties peut-être ces trois parties
normales
ça peut être même plus un géant commencé
à jouer en c3 partie des personnes droit
sur le gong
ah oui important parce que si quand une
partie à deux secondes
ah oui oui c'est un crime bien sûr ça
sera encore mieux surtout ça c'est très
une bonne nouvelle pour ça important
important qui est une partie qui
commence avec deux secondes ce cas la
bonne nouvelle ça quand même femme
ah oui vous pouvoir se délecter un peu
plus bah oui on va embraser les cta fond
la position je connais pas mais je pense
les noirs ont intérêt à vite faire des
trucs
qu'est-ce que sinon je pense tu vas
souffrir entre le centre et par de foot
où ça il faut vite tu actives et au
moins fin des deux chouchous faire un
truc je sais pas et on soit théorique
quand j'imagine massicois reconnaissent
qu'il joue avec avec les blancs mais
j'ai l'impression que j'ai déjà vu ses
trucs et que j'ai quatre dans ces
structures mais tu vois là comme ça
pendant que c'est théorique ça m'est
cher
j'aime pas trop les noirs en fait moi
j'espère pour eux qu'ils ont un truc à
jouer dynamique vite parce que sinon je
crois qu'être faire écraser petit à
petit mais j'ai l'impression que so i
les genres mille fois mieux préparés
abdou après c'est normal mais à jenson
qui fait une différence assez
monumentale dans l'ouverture et il a
gagné déjà une dans l'ouverture
ouais mais là vraiment gagner sur la
prépa donc ça fait quand même un point
entier c'est beaucoup et il a eu des
bonnes positions générales enfin bonne
ce n'est plus agréable pour juste
l'impression web que j'allais noir en
tout cas il ya les repas non surtout aux
4 jusque là il y avait trois pour pour
gwen des fourchettes
non tu perd 2,3 me gagner le fou voilà
donc la tour n'était pas enfermé
d'ailleurs il la bouche de l'amison que
le nouvel s'est bien passé sa place
ouais
est ce que karl scène à 16 ans se serait
fait autant dominé par so no banon caral
scène à 16 ans ils étaient plus forts
non web a été déjà 2007 oui car la scène
à 21 ans il est déjà numéro 1 mondial et
non c'était vers 2011 vahid est de 90 km
189 90 par ouais ouais alors 20 ans
étaient déjà non mais déjà en 2007
donc il avait 17 ans il allait tourner
les candidats iseli match ils veulent un
match très serré contre à rognan je sais
pas si les badges ou perdu de justesse
c'était le choix s'il est perdu de
justesse monde mais tester des matches
s'étaient pas à toi et conduis à
l'époque ces jeux tous très chaud non
mais karl scène le seul qui peut lui
ressemble à un petit peu à l'heure
actuelle c'est firoud déjà et même si
ruud je pense qu'il est en dessous d'eux
car la scène au même âge mais bon
probablement mais bon que au pire aux jo
c'est une des seules qui a quand même
une belle ascension etc
après on voit des petites fées maison
son jeu par ci par là même temps de les
corriger mais il a un truc
est-ce que ça suffira aux boss c'est
toujours dur à dire mais du coup trucs
intéressants
aussi c'est quand même que bon ferroudja
pour aller un peu pour abreuver dans son
sens c'est vrai qu'il arrive à l'apogée
d'une d'une génération car la scène
quand il arrivait il était quand même
hein c'était pas le creux de la vague ce
que les mecs sont encore là haut niveau
et ils sont été monstrueux mais avait
plus kasparov qua non à l'époque ça mais
bon on est encore créé des chroniques à
nantes déjà c'était quelque chose cette
opa l'offre qui est pas dit son dernier
mot il t'avait ont déjà créé deux chocs
et déjà les dés comme ça mais j'ai un
rognon je trouve qu'au moment où il
arrivait du coup de com y avait pas là
aujourd'hui en fait l'art scène du coup
tu as un joueur il y avait le trône à
prendre oui les personnes qui étaient
vraiment assis dessus et qui le gardait
comme un tyran parce qu'en fait tu
arrives dix ans avant il ya kasparov tu
finis numéro un mondial
huit ans après quoi fin ça fait très
très mal ce que tu as même quand
kasparov il arrive à haut niveau
bah oui métacarpe of oak et déjà depuis
juin 15 juin on va dire que carl scène
il arrive au moment où
[Musique]
où il n'ya pas de n'y a pas de patron
quoi en janvier 2008 à 17 ans magnus
carlsen remporte le toit de wisches
kenzy ex-aequo avec les bonnes aronian
et devient le plus jeune joueur à
remporter un tournoi de catégorie vins
auraient tué c'est impressionnant à 17
ans tu imagines mais en fait tu vois je
me repasse le truc son match contre
contrat rognant la cntg utilisait céder
les candidats s'étaient les demi-finales
des confidences
donc il ya 17 ans mais contraint rognant
c'était très loin c'est sais pas comment
c'est le truc une match a duré tout ce
parti quoi il a prédit parti il est à 5
5 il a perdu les deux dernières mais
j'ai pas c'était dur à pile ou du truc
après en tout cas voilà sept ans à l'été
à 17 ans il était déjà table 10 mondial
largement qua non peut-être pas sur le
papier mais en niveau de jeu voilà en
2008 il avait atteint 315 ça a été tout
à fait régulière des 18 ans a été il n'a
pas trop calé au milieu une petite
accélération
ouais la fédé mais oui donc à 16 ans à
16 ans carl scène contre sosa aurait pu
être très chaud en fait voilà peut-être
sous plus fort mais il peut très bien
perdre le match
bah c'est un peu fischer reste qu'un
après voilà enfin ils s'étaient connus
sur la vuelta exactement il a gagné deux
étapes 1 go du jeu de deux belles étapes
de montagne fini huitième du général
il a fait il a fait une grosse boîte à
je pense que ça va être le ca sera
leader à mon avis de la fdj au prochain
tour de france
pinault du coup bon je voudrais mes
trucs j'ai pas trop triste partition
monsieur abdou il est pas mal papa marc
goua s
il a géré plus ou moins y at il un tour
bien active c'est bien ça ouais pour
rich a gagné stowell thouet
marie fait une belle saison du programme
je vais tout d'abord ce week end vuelta
ça va et oui mais vous croyez toujours
way d'être lancé sur vinci c'est ça le
plan de match était de monter droite
c'est une centre mais il va faire à 5g
cinq noms ou c3 faiblissant s'il le fait
ok de 5 on peut tenter de 5.5 c'est ça
ma fille c'est que l'effet rejet et 5
merci beaucoup je prends mes coaches
aidé à toujours chiant je fumais alepian
qu'il en soit centre j'aime bien ouais
mais je pense je pensais qu'il était
sorti du bois tu vois mais pas encore la
dixième jour à 17 ans il a 27 23 et 15
scène avait 27 14e et comme disait fabi
là il est bien monté aussi faut voir
qu'il ya qui a 13 ans 27
14 c'était mieux classée dans le
classement mondial que 23 aujourd'hui
aussi donc c'est un peu d'inflation non
mais giroud déjà ses notables ce qu'ils
faisaient et sur fond orangé this et caf
orange et six pouces et quatre méthodes
tutour quand je suis un maire de tours
produit hier au f5 en fait mais
franchement tu fais tout reprendre à 3
acquise des draps des tourrades non mais
c'est dur à dire mais bon tout ça pour
dire que le seul joueur de la next gen
entre guillemets qu'on peut comparer à
karlsson pour le moment c'est firoud
déjà c'est le seul qui s'approche un peu
de ce qu'il a fait et les autres c'est
pas mon style de jeu mais il a un truc
dans son jeu 'on va lui enlever
autant d'ailleurs que carl scène avait
un style de jeu complètement différent
des autres
enfin il a aussi apporté quelque chose
donc ça en fait ils se ressemblent
dirais pas ils se ressemblent dans le
nord différence dans leurs différences
ils sont liés jambes et bien ça c'est du
cuir jantes alu manger ça c'est du kerry
james est en plein stream c'est beau je
crois que ça à faire perpète
je peux pas attendre mais tour h 15 de
cette façon et tourache troaré le 3-4-3
jusqu'à 3 3 tours j'ai trois quand tu
reviens n'ont nulle pas mal adjoint il
ya dix ans mais bon trois points d'écart
comme un sicilienne mes sauts en fait il
change alors qu'en face ils changent et
changent de ligne et chaque partie et je
sais pas exactement pourquoi tu fais ça
s'il votera pas le temps de réviser
entre les rondes et vu que dominer bien
avec ce qu'ils faisaient avant pourquoi
il se sent obligé de changer en fait
comme je disais peut-être qu'il s'amuse
un toit bajaur l'italienne j'aurais bien
répéter en fait parce que je me sentirai
l'asie trustant le capot peut-être après
la pause qui va vous inquiétez fichiers
je te la changent mais la tendance tout
on imagine la french team jmb lé fil
rouge avec c'était de bosser ensemble
orfi roja est pas français quand même
pour le moment non c'est parce qu'ils
habitent là qui est français non mais il
pourrait peut-être aux enjeux clés sur
enfin qui sait après ça serait plus en
tant qu'aidant pour mvl qu'autre chose
tous deux secondes en comme choses comme
ça quand même vl lansac dans sa vie
avait aidé un peu d'autres joueurs l'ont
été dans la team de magnus
c'est à moi je compte qu'avec in choix
avec maxime il est déjà un peu bosser
avec enfin vous pour me dire chronique à
une époque est longtemps une dizaine
d'années voilà souvent en fait on était
plus jeunes qui donne de l'expérience tu
vois un peu l'exigence que ce tout ça et
puis après respectant ses lois pour toi
même mais mais ça serait pas un travail
d'égalé à égal pour l'instant s'y
retrouvent plus à pirou déjà travaillé
pour maxime que juste partager des trucs
50 50 c'est pas mal assure rock je crois
qu'il ya des 5
ouais avec le foot mais quatre qui
traîne de ce côté brand et 5,4 en dessin
prend 20 et dameuse sa terrible pour
choc dassault qui sert barré alors il a
joué l'amdam g4 et y est parti car bien
bâti c'est la deuxième fois qu'il touche
à tout
c'est la deuxième fois qu'il part
pendant la partie ces grosses mesures de
sécurité pour ce match emilia
d'occasions mais du coup si firoud déjà
et champion du monde ses fils et un
champion du monde iranien ou français
sylvain français parce qu'en fait du
coup ces recalés qui n'est champion du
monde français si tu considères que fit
roja championne en france est allée qui
n'est ce pas ce qu'ils sont jeunes
français quoi qu'il en soit bête je
pense dépend pas des deux roues où tu es
champion du monde
oui mais si tu as des nationalités
talent et de coiffes un franco iranien
mais en gros ce pas ce qui quand il
était champion du monde c'était en 69
il est peut-être jamais mis les pieds en
france à ce moment là je veux dire il
s'en foutait d'être français donc on
peut pas dire qu'elle était champion
français après deux nuls français plus
tard sur la fin de sa carrière télé qui
n'ont peu et qu'il ne peut plus mais bon
enfin pour moi non enfin les concerts
pas qu'on est champion français en fait
ce choix c'est vrai je sais pas c'est
comme grosjean par exemple lors en
formule 1 il un passeport français aussi
mais il est considéré comme suisse parce
que parce qu'il est suisse qu'en fait
ils avaient en fait je n'arrive pas à
comprendre quand tu as des joueurs qui
ont la double nationalité comment tu
choisis pour tu vois ce que tu m'emmènes
fatah plein de plein de sportif de haut
niveau je parle pas causer chacun mais
qui ont deux nationalités en sport
individuel et je sais pas à quel moment
c'est une nationalité qui prédomine plus
que l'autre bah en fait je pense tu dois
considérer aussi commenté fait sa
formation en quoi il est en tout cas
chez rogers n'a pas été fermé en france
n'est pas d'écoles françaises structure
française derrière lui quoi qu'il en
soit parce que l'air plutôt un an ils
puissent iranien quoi mais ça c'est pas
enfin dire ce même bas dans sa
progression il a été formé là bas il a
travaillé que mag lochou avec ta
bataille avec les mecs comme ça tu vas
pas travailler des français de son âge
donc je considérerais plus comme joueur
iranien dans le fond comme parce que je
considère ou pas mais après c'est comme
ils cassent la grèce qui débat en fait
tu vas tu sais qui dessine le pays qui
va le représenter
non en fait c'est juste une question
comme ça pour le sport en général à ce
n'était pas que pour le capcir rogers et
shaw est une question qui m'est venu à
l'esprit tout d'un coup parce que j'ai
pensé à grosjean en formule 1
j'ai en fait c'est vrai que il est
français après paris nice un paquet des
suisses en fait je vous ai grosjean suis
juste un français mais je suis pas trop
la formule 1 après bon enfin fuir ou joy
que ce qu'il est enfin en fait aux
échecs il trouve aujourd'hui toi même
peu importe mais dix ans j'ai restera
pour moi si je suis champion du monde
fil rouge à ce que je sais c'est tout le
bien que je lui souhaite mais ce sera
plutôt une réussite pour la formation
iranienne d échec du coup dans bâloise a
rien moi non parce qu'en plus des îles
ont investi là bas pour les échecs
or comme formateur génération de bons
joueurs non mais ils ont juste vraiment
investis ils ont fait des tournois ils
ont ils ont pu voir que la génération
qui arrive et avec mon mag l'eau
chauffée par son prénom apparemment il a
pris part à rabat et au delà et puis mes
s'appelle gueule aux mille autres jeux
comme ça passait sans pas nulle part
mais une nation de ta question 0
vraiment de grands maîtres passe pas
grand chose et tout d'un coup tu as
quatre cinq mecs comme ça qui pousse
c'est pas le hasard c'est qu'il ya
vraiment une démarche un truc
et donc après ben là c'est bien on peut
se prendre ça comme le mérite français
bravo mais pas tellement contre je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord avec toi ça
restera une civière champion du monde
pour moi ce sera plutôt une grande
réussite de l'école iranienne des échecs
ouais enfin je trouve ça un peu comme de
kpatcha mais du coup on se récupérer un
peu le pas tant mieux pour nous mais
après tu te partagez le les mérites pu
dire voilà très bonne éducation et tout
ce qu'il a reçues avant françois des
moyens à sa disposition elle a été
ensuite si tu présentes comme ça la rnm
mais de prendre tout le crédit
ce serait ça serait s'approprier des
trucs qui n'ont pas d'être contre la paf
et tourcoing qui ce direct en fait à
tanger m l'ordi ça ça va dépasser en
fait le coup des 5 1 tout reprend aussi
les tours g8 qui contre-attaqué là et
j'ai pas encore une s'empare des cinq
tours 6 quand il fait en g8 tu peux
jouer un match trois il y aura pas de
pourpre en g2 pour te dévié c'est bien
joué mais il revient peu dans le match
un tout petit je ne sais pas quel point
sa fin comment juger la position c'est
compliqué mais t'es pas très coordonnée
avec les nerfs en tout cas il en terrain
conquis à val monter une pièce de plus
amené à baisser le jeu mais par contre
comme sow est vachement plus rapide que
lui depuis le début du match
ouais soleil terme et un soutien bien la
baraque
il tient même très bien la baraque
ouais mais même là il a beaucoup de
sauts froid j'ai envie sir michael
stoute ou tempo dans une position comme
ça à face et quand même gagné en fait
j'ai à faire tous réfutent au prochain
il va s'organiser un rythme de pression
la pendaison mais voilà ils menacent sa
bande le droit nous partirons csat nos
parents des 8 bat s'arrête juste être
une caisse de plus bientôt non bah ouais
déjà pu avoir une tour en évitant la
fuite s'est grandement améliorée
stricker et matt a du mal à jeter de
l'attaquant bien tu fais quoi comme
mince j'ai juste eu quelques mois
dommage parce qu'il a pris l'initiative
met bas il ya du faso ça marche parce
qu'ils âge soit soit il a raté un truc
et quelques coups puisque ça avait l'air
des plus intéressants il ya cinq six
coups de sac ou après parfois ça passe
juste pas ça marche ça marche pas que ça
pour toi les valses bar avec le roi
elle vient hanter 7 et sur rv arrive 7e
tour cette saison je compte facebook
cette formule cavalli pourquoi tu t'es
pas tous les deux tout ce temps et
surtout après cette dame prend ensuite
j'ai pas à croquer il a craqué ouais
c'est rare ça de voir so craqué sur les
coups de butoirs d'abord et surtout que
cédric fut ramené de cavalli avait rien
pas juste a du mal à progresser mais je
n'étais pas en danger bon ma première
vraie gaffe de
du macho du match carrément ouais ça
fait plaisir
et du coup il revient dans le 4 et il
revient dans le sérieux il s'est
peut-être un peu un peu laissé griser
temps lâché non mais c'est normal de se
griser m'est arrivé de leurs oeuvres
claquer la pièce y avez joué vous
prouvez quatre ans s'était pas très bien
passé et je pense qu'il a pas trop le
choix et c'était quoi ce jeu et j'ai
enfin quand même grosse grosse grosse
grosse gros mental du côté du côté
ouzbek
il montre quand même les crocs le jeune
un non et le oui est ce qu'il va faire
food et un fossé 2 pour débarrasser de
ce fou et à voir la tour carrée dans
bien quoi qu'il en soit ou tant pis il
faut autre chose et puis je voulais
rester en vie et fois leur temps ni quoi
du coup c'est être plus intéressant de
fifa11 s'il avait le temps de faire car
il ya eu ces atroces serait plus
intéressant de le faire avec le fond f5
en fait d'ouvrir la colonne ben maimon
là le problème c'est qu'il réalise cette
dame prend bessette n'a pas le temps de
rocket ce truc tout le temps oui je sais
ça fait déjà trois pièces mais pas le
tour b 1 1
je crois que t'as pas le temps d un papa
de bon ok tu veux juste faire tomber 8
ici en fait et tu prépares b5
enfin il peut avoir à peu près la même
position tout à l'heure avec le pion b c
comme pas la même tombe héritiers
affaire d'âme bessin qui va échanger
lecavalier va faire chier non qui est
des systèmes cpv steve et en chic ce
qu'a réalisé 7 juin avec ton truc en d6
je fais roi ici je te prie key c8 et
puis tant pis avec jean sassus
débarrasse du fleuve st mais déjà avant
son père pal plombé par la forte chaleur
c'est une différence
ils sont mille vlad bottes pourquoi tu
fous c'est génial c'est pourquoi tu
joues c'est extraordinaire ok bon et
leur entraîneur m bondam b5 pas logique
sinon il observé cinq lui même avec le
hockey est logique vous faites appel
choix qui souffre et j'ai le 7 mai on
peut aussi apprendre tous ravis de
tourcoing de ces débiles donc et les
systèmes pensum logique aussi ce qui va
faire broyer futur roi 17 il est serait
vii pour faire tout réfuta il fait ça
mais à tapas temps juste de brancher pas
si rock roy 17 mai du coup tu te rend
plus qu'indécis sur l'échec tout heureux
quand même chouette endroit de sept mois
moi aussi
j'ai cinq prendre l'espace mais je pense
pas que les blancs soient mieux ici
puisque c'est vraiment la même que tout
à l'heure sa filiale plombé cette phase
a vraiment être le même cas de figure
est donc s'écrire cette version mais
écoutons quand même des pions sont bien
bloqué fou c'est un fou à trois ça peut
être une option à un moment déjà là
c'est 50-50 quoi c'est pas simple a jugé
j'ai un bon je préfèrerais jouer que les
blancs ils savent ce que ça moi j'aime
bien pousser les pions en fait c'est un
heureux ouais mais là du coup ça devient
pas si simple de les avancer
bref j'espère à six dessins qui a essayé
système je calme très sérieux quoi
habache venir avec des amis sérieux déjà
les lecavalier 7 et puis tu as parlé du
pion à la turbie 8 tu vas tu as eu des
échos quoi ici et locke fab libye me
demande comment je vais pousser mes
pions à elle seule dame et ses filles ça
c'est fini
maître yoda tu peux vraiment le mettre à
toutes les sauces
le tata 6 v5 maintenant je comprends pas
en fait à six ce qui est des six baies 5
même je te laisse les deux pions j'en
vois quoi je vais être soutenus par le
fou ça va très vite
je crois qu'en fait vous allez de sosh
j'attends que c'est juste gagner en fait
je dois lui signer on n'a pas des balles
de radio koi mais moi j'ai l'impression
que c'est juste sauvé quatre se relooke
ab4 et imparable changement va donc
c'est un problème faudrait tuer piller
cet été des rois v4 mellifères sur
prenons ce match fait il ya une demi
heure on est en mode bon c'est fini on
est par les angels chatting on croit on
se croyait sur les chaînes de beauté et
là tout d'un coup c'est très chaud quoi
elle at elle dû faire le trou cr x 3 way
à bâle alors là mais il hésite même à
eux mêmes ils hésitent même peut-être
mais bosse bosse bosse on s'en fout de
ta merde moi aussi j'aurais poussé vrai
en fait peut-être on l'apprend après
cette merde
par contre là il faut réfléchir ah oui
sur ab3 il accueille ses six car il est
à 5 imparable et à oui mais du foot à
kout sélection avance c'est fini pas
content tu t'en sors et criblante wesley
so en sueur mais alors la fab
s'il ya bien un truc auquel je
m'attendais alors pas du tout c'est ça
tu vois qu'il craque comme ça sow alors
là c'est le mec mais alors à prix s'est
élevé deux fois pendant le match il
abandonne ses incroyables à ce qu'on vit
fab c'est très surprenant c'est plus si
clair un tout d'un coup plus hein c'est
pas plus 3 20 ouais et puis en plus à et
l'autre bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il
restait quatre minutes que si ce n'avait
pas abandonné il y aurait pas eu la
partie de plus et là on a la partie de
plus ça on est 10e partie dans le cinq
plus ça on va être bien sûr à la fin un
très bonne nouvelle mais il est
incroyable a quand même abdou
franchement franchement je suis sûr sur
luc breysse qu'il faut jouer un coup de
kg 4 un moment où ça absolument que on a
quand même dû devant f3 je crois jouer
comme nous tout est blanc mais pour
éviter que les jets 4
bah ouais voilà ça sert à rien et du
coup on déshabille f3 je crois que pour
m on va te reconnaîtras chose il va
jouer pour f4
ouais g3 g4 tu fais h300 g3 celui que
j'entrevois une autre hypothèse live
search a thing et tu vois c'était
prémonitoire feront pour pas pour ces
quatre sets
j'aime bien les blancs mais après j'aime
toujours les bilans de ces positions là
je me fais toujours défoncé donc mais
j'ai l'impression que je vais faire f 4
je suis à deux doigts de gagner en fait
bah non c'est bien même pas que c'est
que fougueusement il va revivre
donc c'est possible
ris ques les sauces y perd ce match va
envoyer un petit mail à rennes pour
faire banal où il avait des coupes
derrière lui pendant le match
donc voilà mais c'est là en fait ces
terribles et juste mal non j'aime pas
les temps de vie enfin je comprends pas
pourquoi faire poursuites ont fait
retour du 3e tour
un truc et hop mais il a peut-être un
problème après on l'a vu se lever
plusieurs fois pendant le match je sais
pas mais à quelque chose qui va pas à ce
serait la plus grosse surprise est ce
qui serait pas en train de faire pipi
nice pampers aulas le pipi dans les
pampers là c'est terrible
alors là et tu fais des sas que tu
bouffes on sent que tu fais des six ce
que décide de cette année en vie quand
même question pour cette région un faux
lent mais tu t'en prends tu peux te vas
tu vas te faire bloquer par marc taquet
déjà de pièces non mais c'est là qu'il
faut pas de choc en fait bon en gros je
sais pas si tu vois pas qui va pas tu
proposes un but en fin des 6-17 tu vas
fort c'est la torah l'andevi tu vas
faire ton prendre 5 bien se passer
voilà
gaffe voilà pourquoi faut toujours
écouter un fab libye sauvage suis allé
voir mes vacances il va quand même faire
17 mai mais j'ai pas tout compliquer la
vie mais ça permet à notre montre que
c'est ça va faire comme trump
je n'y a pas 5 5 il y avait 5 1
le score a mal été compté par des trench
gtb locks de toi que ce soit arrivé on
ne sait pas d'où c'est ça la gagner des
parties on ne sait pas comment ce serait
beau quoi il a triché quoi voit la
fraude c'est beaucoup il trembler
jusqu'à l'étouffer la norme arrive ce
mardi vers ses comptes twitter de dire
ce qu'il veut parler quoi j'adore aller
mal jusque 20 de parts ou
extraordinaires à yoann pie x 10 6 snow
taux assez extraordinaire et arrêter ce
match 10 à venir qu'ils fissent on
arrête tout tout de suite à 5 4 si le
match continue je peux peut-être perdre
arrêtons maintenant que nous sommes déjà
bien sûr mais oui c'était une connerie
pas prendre de cinq ans fait 20 euros si
tu peux le beauf et que tu en sais rien
mais il a voulu faire plus en fait et il
a fait moins qui peut le plus peut le
moins
voilà le bon on va tout lui arrivait
toujours opposé c'est pas
ça peut faire des trucs quand il ya des
pièces autour
en gros ça ferait ce le cantique l
initiative et a proposé une fois mais
peut-être moins on aura notre parti
alors un temps solis barre non
malheureusement non à juste désolé fable
sarko combien de temps du coup dans dix
minutes je pense à peu près à temps une
petite pause vas-y fais comme jeanne
belles images mais une petite pub pour
être bien sûr ok bon bien sûr j'ai tout
qui bug un point d'écart c'est chaud on
n'est vraiment pas assuré non mais c'est
chaud c'est étonnant d'ailleurs c'est
étonnant on s'attendait pas à un match
aussi aussi serré honnêtement quand même
ok au début du match j'avais dit moi
j'ai donné 1 % maxime 7
après quand il y avait trois quatre
points d'écart so dominer complètement
bon ça semble être le scénario
finalement à la surprise générale mais
sow s'est mis à très mal jouer quand
même il faut il faut le souligner il
s'est mis à déjouer complètement et ça
c'est vrai qu'on s'y attendait pas
forcément et sauf à voir en bullet aussi
oui les favoris de toutes les cadences
mais a mais bon maintenant que le match
est serré et tout franchement je suis
plus sûr de rien basso à partir d'un
moment non été au dessus puis bien en
dessous mais géant une information de
mauvaise partie quoi enfin tu avais
l'impression que j'ai pas et commencé à
faire des fautes on sait pas trop marqué
il a gaffé grave
quand tu avec les opus adam la lapine
ouais ça peut mal en cinq matches
seulement tout cas parce que c'est
panique à fait sans nulle part sont
parties gagnantes avec une baisse de
plus une défaite wayne on écoute ses
ouïes lagaf et puis même quand il est
retourné dans la position avec la
qualité de plus en fait elle était pas
terrible cette position ils auraient dû
le sentir en fait que ça abdou qui a un
peu craqué ouais ouais ça c'est les 5 6
4 et ou non c'est étonnant mais du coup
ils écoutent webos qu'on a les compos
pour ce soir ouais ouais les compos pour
pour le match prend cette petite pause
ouais je crois que tu auras pas de
coupes au point son nom en gros les
normes question que je me pose c'est ce
que sovar élever son niveau de jeu ou
est-ce qu'il est malade on l'a fillon
l'a vu se lever deux fois quand même
c'est quand même étonnant tu vois c'est
pas le style de la maison tout sucre
poppers
non mais tu as qu'il est malade est ce
qu'il a un problème facture il sait il
ya quand même
est ce que c'est un match comme on
vraiment de l'importance trois joueurs
du top 10 mondial alors que le titre de
man u semble plus que jamais prenable
non pas vraiment mais avec le
confinement ça donne un peu plus
d'intérêt dans le sens avec faire
quasiment un an pas qu'il ya plus de
tournois en dur quasiment aurait donc
forcément ça prend de la valeur près en
soit c'est pas des tournois ça a moins
de valeur un tel titre que gagner un
vrai tournant mais mais quand il rien
d'autre bas ça forcément ça plus
intéressant c'est ça c'est complètement
ça on verra bien comment ça joue mais
clairement à sa plus d'intérêt que que
ça n'aurait pu en avoir
s'il y avait eu trop en dur mais ce
qu'il préfère pas se concentrer sur la
préparation va être peut pas préparer
des variantes pendant un an environ
tâter serait pas ta des prépas à petit a
fait le tour non mais surtout qu'à un
moment c'est pas évident donc lui de
préparer tout le temps sans échéance pas
si tu sais que tu attends dans deux mois
bon bah là ok d'un objectif clair mais
en fait tu sais pas ce qu'il y aura des
tournants de l'ulm à terme je ne sais
pas c'est une vraie question d'ailleurs
non mais c'est une vraie question pour
allemand il aurait offert quelques-uns
bien je pense pas qu'il y aura zéro il y
en a sûrement on peut donc en fait avec
mosquée chose à ce truc ne pas jouer
deux moteurs à celle possible parce
qu'il est pas aux candidats c'est un
tort c'est un ton appris à utiliser ce
sera celui-là jarry championnat us
commencent à en faire pas mal en ligne
je peux la gagner tout vient des états
unis
voilà donc ils commencent à prendre ce
chemin là voyager en europe machin
comment ça va se passer
ben il peut très bien passer une belle
année sans jouer donc voilà on montre t
prépa ça va quoi non mais clairement s
et
c'est une chance quelque part pour les
tournois en ligne qu'il n'y ait pas de
tourner un autre bain de la concurrence
puis ça augmente l'intérêt parce qu'en
même si on veut sur un peu des
compétitions africaines mais y'a que ça
et à voilà donc donc voilà donc ça va
faire un train de fleurir sur internet
après faut pas qu'il y en ait trop trop
trop savants ça fait un peu épuisement
un peu on peut voit la soul et du bien à
la pause mais ça va reprendre de folie
je te le dis tout de suite à partir de
fin novembre
non mais peut-être s'il y en a un par
mois pourquoi pas mais si ça joue à tous
les trois jours qu'il ya un tournoi là
attendant ici un tournoi je sais pas
quoi on s'y perd 7 nuls en jeu enfin sur
l'épreuve attend la vente chez scot doit
se frotter les mains même en termes de
gens qui s'inscrivent en vrai j'ai
l'impression que les tournois organisés
ils n'ont pas une énorme un énorme
impact sur le nombre de nouveaux joueurs
en revanche sur évidemment le
confinement et c'est ça c'est un réel
impact pour pour pour les sites 1 c'est
surtout les poignées tennis un peu
importe que j'aime te fait venir plus
que que 50 speech est très clairement
époque celle de sony où ils vont refaire
ou non non non la crk plus de 100 banon
mais les 2e puck j'aime pas quand même
assez mal marché en réalité attention il
ya une pause méritée qui va avoir lieu
vrai nom mais que c'était un peu bizarre
de faire un putsch et enfin le premier
nom mais dans celle d'hier est un second
comme ça je sais pas des décisions qui
m'échappe ouais mais après c'est une
règle marketing qui marche pas mal c'est
a fait un truc qui marchait c'est bien
d'enchaîner mais juste
oui mais peut-être que ça a marché parce
que c'est un coup terrain et c'est avec
ça marcherait ce sujet ce qui te pose
un moment de répit et que l'ancien
havrais c'était pas mal de trucs je
revois mais si tu les abreuve de partis
cnra commune mais un truc a marché une
fois ce pas dire que ça a marché parce
que saluer tous les jours oui car
moi-même même un tour de france en fait
peut-être que c'est si suivi parce que
c'est une fois par an et aurait trop
tour se rend cet art en peut-être que le
troisième chance à faire un tour de
france par mois de trois semaines et
repas roule à fond quoi mais oui bien
sûr savoir si bien parce que tu as même
bon sens a parlé plein de fois ce que
tata le système des tournois de
préparation des machins des trucs qui
petit à petit monte l'appréhension ceux
qui sont vraiment passionnés à garder
ton à la préparation puis ceux qui
voient qu'ils regardent de loin ils
regardent que le tournoi principal c'est
la bonne manière de faire fabas toute
façon tu vois même là que cette année
donc le foot moi qui suis à fond dans la
ligue des champions je m'en fous parce
que de mettre m s'est fini fin août
machin je ne sais pas je peux le dire
moi je m'en fous complètement
bon ok j'ai pas mon équipe qui joue donc
peut-être que ce sera différent je sache
elle parfaite mais je sens que c'est pas
de souffle préfet lui s'attaque aux
échecs
si tu me souviens de 90000 joueurs lors
de la finale c'est pas mal non mais en
fait le truc sic mais n'importe quel
gros streamer et tu vas voir beaucoup de
joueurs genre c'est comme la même si
avec fab on décide de se mettre en jazz
chatting il va y avoir plus de monde que
d'autres chaînes françaises qui vont
suivre le speech est en fait le nombre
de gens qui regardent ça peut aussi être
un peut faire un truc pas ok tu mets
squeeze par exemple les airs à tort
qu'ils font une partie sur twitch tu
mets 20000 euros il y aura plus de monde
que pour karl scène
nakamura si on commente en france est en
fait juste qu'on va commenté en français
il y aura les quatre cinq mille
personnes que ça intéresse en france
maximum et humer squeeze zerator avec
leurs communautés y aura cinquante
soixante mille personnes fait tu peux
pas à lutter à séparer avec le poc
chaîne mais en gros ça intéresse surtout
les gens de la communauté mais pas
vraiment au sein des échecs c'est ce que
je veux dire
donc le deuxième c'était moins moins
besoin que le premier du coup s'il avait
pris d'aider twitter encore moins connu
ça au rsa aurait trop baissé en fait les
larrieu une demande pourquoi le type de
personne pas plus atteignable que
j'avais annonce je sais pas si c'est
quelqu'un qui dise à tout à l'heure mais
à vrai dire je sais pas pourquoi il a
dit ça en fait non pas pour cette énième
maintenant qu'il l'était ya deux ans il
reste sera favori qui jouent contre
n'importe qui ça veut pas dire que c'est
inatteignable mais reste numéro un
voilà le dessus de la mêlée il est bien
au dessus de la mêlée non mais c'est un
énorme joueur incarne cette c'est
vraiment mais vraiment incroyable après
est-ce qu'un maxime pourrait le déranger
dans un match de championnat du monde
c'est une question quand même qu'on peut
se poser un nom mais le truc c'est que
il n'a pas été impérial dans ses matches
6 contre qu'avec in 6,6 comme carole 1
donc en fait c'est faisable mais ça pour
boîte est en tout cas pouvoir et ceux
qui surtout que s'il tend à des
candidates finit jamais ça être
compliqué d'aller le chercher c'est pas
faux non mais peut-être y amenant donc
trois des candidats restent finir tu
prends ce nom vous faudra finir ou
l'arrêter enfin c'est tu peux pas
maintenir un tournant en suspens et le
reprendre
à mi-chemin trois ans plus tard non jean
cinq spéciales mais je sais pas prêtes
et ont signé des clauses des trucs que
en fait de reprendre à coûte que coûte
même temps 28 ans mais on a vu que ça
s'arrête surtout dû déjà reprendre ça tu
étais en soi mais je sais pas oui bien
sûr soit c'était possible ah bah oui
c'était il ya eu il ya une période
il ya une fenêtre de tir j'ai une grosse
fenêtre de tir il ya eu au moins un mois
et demi deux mois
mais là j'ai peur que la fenêtre de tir
se soit plutôt à fin avril début mai et
a en plus ça va dépendre comment les
états vont cette fois-ci gérer la fin de
la crise est-ce qu'on refait open bar
asie ravaz il y aura une troisième vague
direct après tant pis on s'en fout
organes passé deux mois de vacances ou
est ce qu'on fait quand même un peu les
frontières soient trucs plus
protectionniste se diront cantonne un
peu plus asiatique après après les
compétitions a les clés compétition
sportive se déroule malgré eux mêmes et
de tête et où on aura des pays qui
seront plus réticents à faire partie
afin d'artois les chinois est ce qu'ils
vont te laisser partir comme ça je sais
pas en question
c'est vrai que tu as les chinois de
série que tu as les chinois dans
l'équation n'aurait pas les chinois je
t'aurais dit non ça va le faire ça avec
les chinois ça peut être puisque eux on
vous ne voulez pas que qu'ils aient de
cas importés en fait tu vas en chine tu
as ton ferme et deux semaines à l'hôtel
ces tribus mais je crois qu'ils ont mais
ce n'est pas je crois que la chine a
carrément bloqué les visas de sortie
pour les joueurs
là c'est possible je sais pas ce qu'ils
font mais je sais plus exactement ce que
c'était j'avais lu pour les candidats
mais je crois que les joueurs chinois
ont n'ont carrément pas eu
l'autorisation d'y aller en fait c'était
juste pas possible en fait tu pouvais
pas partir à les jouer de ce truc
concrètement ou pour pour revenir ou
quoi oui c'est une gérance à fait vrai
c'est en asie très près du tout le
l'épidémie même manière que nous
observer qu'ils ont trois cas ils sont
en alerte générale
et ils veulent stopper le truc direct
nous on se dit oui puis à 5000 cas c'est
bien on sera bon donc je sais pas qui a
raison qui a tort
c'est même pas le débat c'est juste que
vu que tu gères paraître la même manière
ça va maintenant
c'est vrai qu'il y avait pas savait pas
les joueurs chinois ça aurait été assez
simple je pense à organiser wade était
même très simple à mon avis mais là là
c'est vrai que ça peut ça peut ça peut
compliquer le truc
on verra surtout qu'en plus les chinois
n'ont aucune chance de se qualifier les
deux ou quasiment
donc ça qu il à 50% donc en fait tu peux
pas vraiment l'exclure comme ça bon
digne c'est sur lui bon allez on va dire
que l'on garde en plus il veut pas jouer
donc j'ai encore ce serait digne qui
sera plus un tu pourrais dire oui mais
qui veut jouer le gouvernement chinois
devrait peut-être bon le mec tu peux
quand même faire champion du monde
d'échecs c'est pas mal de tête tu vois
ça facilite la faute à deux gars déjà
c'est pas un temps a un des deux qui est
déjà largué talent autres ça le fait
chier dit allez enfin tu vois je le vois
pas aller au ministère
ouais bon ça me fait chier d'y aller
mais il faut les packs wii voir il va
pas forcer bah oui oui mais j'ai en fait
si tu as nega le mec va être champion du
monde est tout fléché pas il se bouge
pas il fait des trucs quoi oui j'ai
absolument vous en avez joué ce tournoi
son choix est disqualifié je peux être
champion du monde dont l'avon la vie
pour l'odeur de clélie way for du parti
communiste a amené beaucoup plus
important le pays pas trop mais le parti
peut-être mais du coup oui alors que
s'installe à ce que fait souvent tu si
tu prends prend projet qu'à 3 h un tu
peux plus rockets n'ont ni d'un côté ni
de l'autre pas déjà dès maintenant dire
mais est-ce que c'est grave mais
je n'ai pas envie hein oui je sais pas
ce qu'il fait en droit de lancer quatre
pour y propager 4 avant de faire ça mais
peut-être qu'ils aient peur de tanger
med en f3 ou alors il a fait tous rêvent
depuis l'autre tourangelle gamme c5 d'am
dam dam des quatre dames c5 aussi les
touristes car j'aime bien qu'ils aient
tour f8 laquelle d'ailleurs c'est une
question ça c'est une vraie question
ces cinq là pas du tout très peu l'autre
jeu l'autre mais un bon ok bah il veut
il se classe et sans bien jouer c'est le
5/7 fichiers caisse des ceintures ça tu
peux pas là c'est sûr que c'est
davantage la version qu'il a péché par
par contre rien petit peu bref de machin
ouais c'est à ceux-là est à nouveau très
très bien ce serait bien pour lui de
gagner ça leur fera un petit break dans
ce match le 5
ok qu'elle ait des six agents s'est pas
fait encore un pas ce qu on sait bien
qu'on puisse c'est que un peu plus
cavalier ces cas tu as cannes qui prend
b2 peut-être que ces quatre cas il n'y
est pas allé en tout cas well as il
arrive en d6 à faire mal ce cas la case
f7 le pion b cette belle pioche et ses
luttes du coup que l'autre après si sow
se réveille et qui se remet en marche
comme il l'était au début du 5 + 1 il
peut dans mon avis assez rapidement et
facilement reprendre 4 5 de didace un
ami caissier de saper tous les jours
c'est 3-1 bêtement pour ses sets je suis
pas trop ce qui peut jouer
il est juste raymone bain pour ces trois
courses et trois tours c7
c'est un peu la crise quoi web on attend
qu'il ya eu 7 encore il prend 17 et
reprend des quatre qu'il attaquera j'ai
4 dead space 2 d'abord qu'avait lieu de
défendre le pion ils sont tous les deux
joueurs alors oui ce les sauts et
l'américain mais d'origine fille plein
appui piégeage pas compter ça a été des
philippines à la base enfin il est suivi
par ailleurs en réalité et puis
maintenant il est évident qu un bon
moment ça fait peut-être dix ans de ça
là et ça tough c'est un annus bec plus
jeunes 16 17 ans à cette europe fait où
est ce qu'ils sont ils pas très vieux
mais d'avoir 27 lente il se fait
tellement longtemps qu'il est parmi les
meilleurs mondiaux qui ont attaqué plus
que ça mais mais il est un peu plus
jeune que la génération karl scène quoi
c'est un peu la même génération mais de
trois ans - quoi il avait été retardé
dans sa carrière par un problème de
fédération d'ailleurs wesley il n'avait
pas pu jouer pendant un an ou un an et
demi qu'elle sait qu'à 3 des 4 ça te
stresse qui avait six méchant sur razak
d'autres questionner mais je demande
encore il est si gagnant que ça encore
qu'il a quand même rendu le pion mais
c'est bizarre le nombre de finales de
cavaliers qu'on a aujourd'hui parce
qu'elle est assez rare général fabien
finale deux tours c'est tout le temps
c'était un mais trois finales de
cavaliers depuis le but du match
elle est intéressante celle là c'est
bien ce que fait à wesley
dans six bruno jobs sur des lunettes
noires un formulaire par une haie j'ai
fait j'ai pas la réf
je sais pas mais ils ont tous des
erreurs et des gens non c'est pas si
clair parce que truc c'est que ces dames
dames et shalem échec mais un cavalier
va revenir le 2 1
mais ce que je peux revenir avec son
cavalier genre puisqu'il a fait qu'elle
je pensais qu'il allait faire je pensais
qu'il est peut-être un vrai nom ça
marchait pas je pensais qu'ils allaient
faire cavalier machin qui a eu quatre
équipes range étroit et essayer de faire
ça et se dire que le car elle est propre
protéger la case de promotion vont
maintenant c'est passé un peu mais oui
bien jouer un wesley cas d'être allé
prendre le pion et tout faire roi
bessette c'est bien
bon il faut il faut qu' il faut cap d'où
ils reviennent ils reviennent tout de
suite faut pas qu'il fasse comme tout à
l'heure de cesser trop mettre à l'écart
parce que je pense que wes et ne donnera
pas une deuxième chance fab compteur
mais il lui laisserait il ne sera pas
une nouvelle chance
bon ok ça ait changé et d5 j'imagine
donc
non écoute mon mieux que prévu
ouais mais là encore elle a sa petite
position il n'est pas spécialement mieux
mais c'est quand même un poil plus
agréable pour les blancs non web on se
régale bien oui mais c'est quelque chose
là en tout cas tu peux pas tu joues quoi
ouais non mais avec les blancs il fait
l'obtient rien mais le des potions qui
chevauche général et c'est aux bronches
où il menait 5-4
taquin comme le centre moi j'aime bien
ce genre de structure mais bon après je
sais qu'en réalité c'est un peu une
chimère quoi c'est pas si fou que ça ne
sera jamais un grand depuis on sent trop
mais après oui c'est tu prétends pas
vraiment al'avantage on va voir s'il
peut être une petite pression jouer vite
et bien tout ça tu te fous prend b3 qui
réussissent une messe ou 3 il va juste
prendre être quatre en forme et 3.4 mais
quoi que vous preniez trois prises avec
quatre rails français de wes à tour 6-1
et de me prendre de trop ouais ben du
coup il a été obligé de reprendre du
piolet caire est donc ça va complètement
pour les noirs sa belle occasion des
cadres pour l'utiliser quand il veut
pourquoi pas dès maintenant d'ailleurs
donne des quatre ok basso ils échangent
dû souvent les aminches et continue non
c'est vrai que c'est un match sous le
signe de l'échangé la même si abdou fait
il allait les parties où il a réussi à
gagner finalement c'est celle où il a
envoyé un chat salle où il a envoyé le
machin ou wesley a perdu à donner la
tour en a eu il quelques attaques plus
ça lui a réussi quoi mais après bon
c'est pas si simple d'arriver à
l'attaqué ce où il était encore noire
solide le placent ces pièces tout ça
c'est dur de forcément aller
mettre des lettres en avant elle avait
peut-être un peu entrouvert la porte
saut à jouer des trucs oui c'est ça un
peu attaqué là on voit qu'il a quand
même bien refermer le truc hein mais je
devais rhinoise wasquehal mais tout ça
c'est les trois logiques ou tard pas le
cavalier mais après du coup ça va un
petit peu avec pierre détroit quand
faut-il arriver à l'attaqué c'est ça le
projet c'est pour ça qu'il a perdu du
temps à faire un petit aller-retour en
d4 6k liens utiles et super bien placé
on puisse y défend g7 peut-être d'un
bet5 madame zinc et être créé des
problèmes
probablement pas noble et 5 et décision
prend juste des trois ilets ficib l'un
d'eux vient d'abaisser ce bien joué
j'attaque bessette place la dame
défendent et deux points marqués dans le
dessin ou sow est ce qu est ce que des
tours à et un coup ici j'aurais fait
tourner pour pas laisser tour à 8,1
c'est logique mais ce que tour des huit
salons bt pas du coup ouais c'est ce que
je me disais tu troquer des trois
comptent 17 mai du coup à jouer à l'as
active et donc c'est important de
bruxelles ouverte à c'est ce que nous
vraiment ouverte de chic et pas fin donc
mais bon ici s'il prend qu on prend ta
des pions doublé bête qu'est assez bien
pour les blancs ça probablement même
gagné en ans
c'est mieux j'ai gagnant pas sûr mais tu
dois être dans le règne de proches de
gagnant quand même pas moins que
concrètement tg ce qui menace en d4 et
qu'on arrive qu'on doit faire des cinq
essais 5 et qui bloque mais était quand
même et par l'eau avec des blancs et
noirs
qui sait dans le daniel orange de cap je
suis le cio à lord est à la retombée
catch bouge très vite en b 4 mai ag si
sûr car ie7 qui essaient 6 termine à dos
non mais c'est fou en fait ce qui se
fait un peu stratégiquement sow dominé
dans ce match d'autres comme si ce
n'était pas le bon coup que d'hommes des
cinq sites web il a laissé dame b 6 mai
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si c'est
abdou qui joue vraiment très bien aussi
c'est mes sauts il me paraît un peu
tendre aujourd'hui je sais pas j'ai
l'impression de parler reconnaître la
chebba sais je suis hyper étonné en fait
ils ont peut-être que l'autre très bon
sujet va oir non mais je suis je suis un
peu interloqué tu vois je le voyais là
encore une partie simple et où ils
repèrent et ils repèrent failli se fait
vraiment ce match est en fait surtout
cap doit pas du tout gagné le speech
junior quoi donc tu vois enfin fouillé
même pas qui c'est c'est ça va tout seul
c'est assez sarine qui a gagné donc tu
vois il et il était même pas en finale
il joué contre sara nage plus content
qu'il a perdu abdou mais après il avait
peut-être un problème de connexion quoi
mais peu importe il m'a pas marqué tu
vas dans le sillage du mieux donc tu dis
bon enfin après bon ça peut arriver de
faire un mauvais match ou quoi mais tu
aie aie pas c'est pas le gars le plus
dangereux de l'univers quoi
voilà un sens qu un peu ce matin à
sentent donc juste pour vous dire la
faire bref 8c des rockets mais il
n'avait pas envie de marquer ses 6 et
les blancs faire [ __ ] en cavalier b
prend et fixer ce prix qu'à soir auprès
9e coup je pense qu'ici je suis pas sûr
qu'il aurait bouffé kirya 4 et et voilà
donc il est des rockets mais c'est un
centre fermé
donc on sait pas trop ouvrir c'est moins
grave et donc ils espèrent pouvoir
ensuite peut-être sortir son foot 15
manches 6 faire rager cette affaire
comme un roc voilà oui mais peut-être
pas y arriver mais c'est pour ça qu'il
joue comme ça c'est un peu bizarre
vouloir mieux voir le rang 8 mai ça
explique en gros mehal et blanc ils
menacent river l'acef pranger 6e
peut-être parce que le pion avec cet été
en surcharge sur six est sûre j'ai six
balles de set et a défendu mais en tout
cas il ya notre côté w9 donc je verrai
devant ce vers du nez va il ya peu dans
le dur mais nous travaillons tous eu
tort je pensais juste perdu en direct
des cinq petites vites sa masse est
d'ailleurs qu'avec n'importe où la dame
à 7 tu penses qu'il avait vu à l'avant
ce jeu c'est pas son temps de réaction
fera dire que non mais chez ba peut-être
parce que je trouvais qu'il est admis
longtemps gb 5 alors que si tu as prévu
que prévue c'était forcément j'ai pu
non mais c'est pourtant vrai ce que
dante c'est tu te rends katappa vub et 5
ces grosses réussites ah bon il capte
pied pour le ciss et b4 ou b4 direct
chez pas ce qui la rend tellement envie
de prendre six mois je serai content car
de prendre aussi tu persistes et b4 et
adama qu'adam g 5 7 a besoin d'attaquer
g600 cuse cet été quelle est sa puce de
pièces des trucs seringue au carnage
malgré tout ce que fout g7 il est
vraiment pourri avis car même avec les
blancs tu vois tu
positionnelle georges et 3h 4h dieu le
fou g7 il sentira plus jamais de sa voix
donc tu peux faire l'accent avec pour le
beau jeu mater droite soit 1 kg 6 tu
peux enfermez-le attia s'enfermer tu as
beaucoup de deux trucs sympa à faire
hacker blancois asséchant nous faut pas
se prendre de fourchette de 3 ans tu
mens mais sinon dépression est vraiment
réguler sais pas quand il va essayer de
défendre sa l'ouzbek sans plus et mba
qui menacent encore un tour à 625 c'est
bien le doyen bah écoute il va se battre
mais très très peur non ça va être
complètement réglé il fera cap tout
raciste sud j
il fait mal hein eh ben c'est pas nous
c'est fou g7 quand ils se font au mur
est en fait tu joues avec des pièces en
moins il a le g7 senora retombe sur le
set et on va bien le jeter à la poubelle
- tu dois au moins je fais fouet suite
il ressort il fait un truc je ne fais
rien du coup ils sacrifient à et tente
un truc tu prends des équilibres ont
probablement pas marché du tout ouais
bah c'est juste qualité de moins et il
n'a toujours pas de foi c'est toi sur
ton pire est passé et a peur de tomber
je suis pas enfin je note qu'on va faire
tomber un tournant pour trouver ses
seins et la turquie en iran assistions à
cette aide à main je pense c'est assez
joli coup de main tout à fait un joli
nom c'est sympa la joue vite rythme
parce que n importe quoi avec veut faire
distribuer ses 5 pouces et 5 c'est pas
mal aussi un toit à 7 au prochain
passage philippe un juge
terrible
mais bon ils essayent de défendre quand
même bon
là il tient par un sur un fil mais il a
déjà la qualité de moins la fouge est un
il est vraiment si nomura plein d'air
c'est pas mal quoi ce qu'il a à faire
donc ça c'est quoi ton foutu mais il te
rend pas la tâche facile
on va te refaire un fou mais quatre
n'ont eux tenter un truc alain minc ont
même changé
si on prend qui on prend étape à
darmstadt la tourache si c'est vrai ça
marche pas du tout mais à 80
robin g3 peut-être fois jeu de j 3 6 à
12 ans je ne prends rien ni 4 et lada
les autoroutes non damée faisait il ya
pas trop plongé trois puisque c'est sur
échec mais alors rien du tout mais fois
ce 5 mai n'y a rien en fait c'est dans
ce domaine
wei nouveau maire en fait mais y'a rien
parce que une tour autour de moi et il
s'est démené quand même il s'est démené
de ouf quand même par et c'est pour ça
que nous on réussira jamais à le battre
en fait
bah c'est chiant parce qu'ils te mets
des peaux de banane qui se faire par son
accueil qui est des quatre héros keita
leurs abeilles offert ouais ok bon il
joue ce genre de position spéciale
après c'est à lui qu'il faut aussi
déjoué saut en défendant aussi bien tête
à force tu fatigues un côté à côté
américain la sauvette il ya peu de temps
fatigué ouais c'est impressionnant alors
qu'il est mal autant et il joue vite
mehdi ou plutôt bien il n'a pas fait il
n'a pas vraiment dans les designs
notamment les positions reds n'a
quasiment jamais donné une partie en un
quoi
terrible après son style ouais merde tu
as a raison c'est je m'accroche je
m'accroche ouais mais bon il peut finir
mondiale un une bonne vision tactique
tout ça quelques pas mal a l'air de très
bien calculé vrai je te confirme
non c'est quand même un gros joueur mais
sur x fils ici je crois oui la la la il
fait la tête de quelqu'un qui a gaffé la
reine si la phase 4
ouais là il a gaffé il va tenter quoi il
va tenter fou g5 peut-être prise crise
et si tu vas me voir je pense moi il ya
eu match 4 ira jusqu'à toi tu auras pas
d'âme pranger 4 le truc ça être attaqué
pardon c'est pas le coût de la partie en
forme beaucoup après un ouais bah c'est
d'accueil chez 4,1 de moins pour m
voyant plus truc horrible c'est que kg
et 4 tu peux le laisser installer
puisque tu es que tu le prends il a
ajouté qu à l aller à ses yeux le
pouvoir songer à chercher aussi ses
crocs des attaques et un parfaite c'est
vraiment le pion que tu veux pas avoir
perdu un catastrophe toi bah écoute on
va voir on va s'accrocher à la base une
partie importante pour saw ii pas la
gâcher parce que il repassera plus 3 est
donc là un retrait d'ailleurs et repris
le truc qui avait lâché tout à l'heure
c'était tellement dominant au début donc
la science et à faire un petit tour h7
pour défendre et camp rock tour à schwyz
où avec quelque chose mais a oui oui il
était il était hippie ultra dominant et
ça va lui faire du bien de reprendre
l'avantagé
qui était le sien les actes ça te donne
toujours tout marche qui a été un petit
moment de vous turpin katia d'europe
sans avoir défendre f7 puisque madame
pranger qu'adam fin septembre le projet
mirax et quand même d'autres il est
serein
je viens aussi oui oui mais gérard c'est
quand même à c'est pas du tout dans le
style est quoi un jeune garçon bros sur
wii c'est pas du tout moi j'en ai même
pas songé à petit rock en fait je dirais
me 38 allait bien jusqu'à 24 je voulais
mais je pense beaucoup nombreux pour ces
coms
ouais mais tu vois c'est ce qui nous
sépare peut-être aussi du top niveau 1
quand je vois les matches de maxime etc
je vois qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
choses que nous on n'envisage même pas
et qu' ils font
voilà je suis d'accord avec toi hein que
grand que ça paraît vraiment logique
mais mais j'ai l'impression quand même
qu'ils ont une vision beaucoup plus
large que nous son visage plus d'options
en fait est ce que tu peux en venir
remettre leurs 10 au 19 pouces et 3
juste à savoir si mecha le premier où je
vais surfer en fait il ya eu ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre s'en fout wii fit
grand bruit dans les mariages
quand même si ça tient jusque là c'est
sûr je sais qu ils ont le plus de
gestion de plus de trucs qui roxx
clautre séquelles et l'on se fie larges
morceaux c'est hyper défensif mais il
sait calculer mais très bien je veux
dire c'est pas et en gros si c'est le
bordel
il saura faire il va juste pas vraiment
créé par les 26 pays vitesse mais si tu
vas le chercher
hélas la durée vous sur l'ordi la vue
qu'on l'allumé c'est moins quatre femmes
non mais c'est un carnage on sait que
pour moi mais quand tu auras de
l'activité les pièces leroy faible foot
et de pourri la doivent à ce jour c'est
parce qu'elle fait enfin y'a rien qui
vaille et d'un mètre cinquante à dam des
cinq très bien je pense carnage mais
aurait fait perdre au curage 4 mai déjà
alors je lâche 4 il est trop de cases
ouais et ça fait plus 3 et s est un peu
inquiétant pour pour abdou dans le sens
où l'on fab
il va il repasse à -3 et là du coup si
sow a pas ça surmultipliée qui le laisse
pas s'échapper
ça va faire ça à faire très très mal ça
va faire très très mal
je me dis qu'il ya deux tu es dans
l'ondam satarov peut-être que j'en ai
oublié un ici
après le chauffard illico si les ouzbeks
je pense buck en fait monter d'hôtesses
en fait c'est très difficile à dire et
d'ailleurs je pense qu'en français sont
non moi je les écris à la halle anglaise
enfin j'ai fait un mélange émis les deux
êtres que ça ce qui est ce mais du coup
j'aurais dû mettre un mot aussi c'est
c'est pas facile en fait tu peux
l'écrire de plein de manières
différentes
no more bon ok ce carreau kahn qui a eu
son heure de gloire à la mode alors que
oprah m6 il ya 55 personnes jouer comme
ça mais il ya une petite poussée une des
livres écrit un peu là-dessus
intéressant tu as fait une vidéo sur
czech comme d'ailleurs et des gens qui
m'ont dit qu'ils avaient besoin ouais
ouais j'ai fait je sais pas je peux
retourner s'était investi avait publié
je te dire j'ai des gens qui m'ont dit
qu'ils avaient regardé que ça avait
beaucoup aidé un autre est bien pour
mieux non moi je d'imagés moi j'avais vu
avant qu'elles soient publiées mais je
les ai vues publiées 1 c'est sûr on me
l'a dit de façon à les gens qui m'ont
dit ah tiens il ya aussi la vidéo de fab
là dessus après les gens ne décrivent
pas quoi il ne te disent pas jawad et
galaxy l'a vu le nom il ya plus d'argent
sur le chat qui m'ont dit qu'ils avaient
vu leur garde et c'est pour les trouver
ces dans l'onglet lauzon mais alors
c'est vrai que sur czech comme mise à
part les leçons de base c'est il ya
masse de bonnes leçons mais qui sont
assez difficiles à trouver en fait dans
la navigation dans son cachet major ta
vidéo moi je les ai vus parce qu'elle
venait de faire déjà gelé vue avant
parce que je les ai vus à après après le
montage mais
mais après je n'ai pas pu dire vu en
vidéo mais tu vois je serai pas comment
la retrouver en fait tu vois
concrètement je comprends je pourrais
pas dire de quelle manière retrouver
exactement cette vidéo en fait oui c'est
compliqué je vous propose en fait ils te
mettent déjà par niveau c'est très
compliqué peut-être bien avancé mais je
crois que c'est encore dans ses pièces
c'est encore dans un autre endroit qu'il
faut chercher je crois que tu es dans un
mot c'était dans l'endroit logique mais
c'est pas dans cet endroit là un de gea
pour te dire à quel point c'est pas
facile mais je sais quand je trouve ça
j'essaie d'être essayée cei si tu
trouves tu me dire
si tu ne trouves tu me dis jeune dame
non ses dents longues garde jeu s'est
passé c'est dommage parce qu'en fait la
leçon à elles sont très bien mais tu as
du mal
ils disent dans leur nez stratégie web
et tu vois les noms leur nez stratégie
mais c'est ce que j'ai en fait à un
endroit où tu vas l'a trouvé facile mais
en fait tu vas pas dans cet endroit là
tu vas jamais la trouver
donc là on apprendre le il n'ya pas
longtemps j'ai ce sont les leçons de
kochi kane sur polgar ouais ouais
ea est en fait j'ai retrouvé via google
quoi alors où sont honorés de défense on
peut lire en fête pour dire vrai c'était
pas mal joué chicken vous en avez marre
de queen is gambeat appelé kôji kane
avec kocik hey vous aurez toutes les
plus belles parties de pôle gare analysé
en vrai c'était pas mal oui sans rigoler
il rend des coachs de colbie caillat
masse de cours de kôji kane eux
il a fait un truc soit veulent ouais
mais ils sont pas mal ces courants plus
coach week end c'est vraiment d'avoir
mixer le délire que jikan avec la dncg
trouver [ __ ] et arcoa le sol peut être
faisant apprendre et je vous faire il
faut pas faire le sont offerts vidéo
nice et ça c'est ce que j'ai essayé
c'est ça il ya un truc à faire et après
tu trouves nos bases
non mais les gens bien nés ont bien aimé
ont bien aimé ta vie de rares y en a
combien en finale il y en a quatre
deux cars aux cadres comme ça et de
donner aux cds puis en double à chaque
fois oui mais non c'est intéressant
c'est intéressant et du coup ça ça avec
l'abonnement diamant et 11 minutes
une de 13 de 14 une de 13 avec la bonne
lan diamant regardez les vidéos de
femmes
vous en avez marre de perdre avec les
pions isolée appelée coach fab des
chevaux dans sa position s'est
correctement foutu pour pour abdou tous
les stores h7 en plus n'ont pu me +4 ça
y est ouais c'est sow s'est envolé non
je sais ton vol est oui mais devrait
verser une petite variante récupère des
pièces qui est prendre à prendre des
cinq mois ça peut faire nul tu faire
échec et que la dame y couche tard une
très belle partie contre un certain
allen bacrot donc comme ça ouais bon
c'était pas exhaustive mais oui comme ça
comment c'est terrible a joué un de ces
quatres on va s'organiser le match à
contrebas qui en deux sets gagnants là
il va falloir que je le prends trop vite
ça est très difficile mais le truc c'est
que j'ai dit il me faut du temps on va
faire ça gg je me prépare à fond en fait
il n'aura pas uniquement parce qu'il me
dit l'autre jour quand on a fait le
match en bulles à de bas qui fait
pendant le match mais ouais tu étais pas
mal et tout est bien battu mais mais
après une vie j'ai regardé le replay
mais en fait tu sais que tu es renaître
dans toutes tes scandinave après il dit
cook
ben oui c'est quand même pas facile de
jouer un match contre un adversaire plus
un pendant tout le match sans fin
c'est dur un moment donné c'est toujours
être tout le temps quoi gâcher votre les
pressions où il a peur de flou et tout
ça en fait ce qui est génial avec la
scandinave c'est que n'importe quelle
variante qu'on te ajouté mal en fait
ouais après des biens les ressources
tout ça est vrai que tu devrais faire je
ne pourrais pas dessus et puis attend
juste chiant même en bullet c'est chiant
parce qu'ils veulent après pas eu là la
paire de fou baky à la petite finale
avec la paire de fous qu'ils jouent
pendant pendant tout le bullet c1 c'est
dur quoi t'es mal ou toulon baki
ba qui prend à mango acadiens et bac il
est marrant quoi l'autre matin ils
m'appellent peut-être dans le chat du
week-end
hier tu as fait le tft on n'a pas
compris les règles tuerie expliques tu
vas qu'il était chaud qu il voulait
regarder le tf tf1 s'est dit non mais
vas-y ré explique bien résout du coup
était content and are fois je les prie
en live quand je lançais le tfc et en
live et on a fait le début oui oui bon
je peux regarder au moins il y as couché
tranquille avec le petit selon hubert
des babillards quoi c'était
extraordinaire je vise c'est quand même
débit jusqu'à trois heures du match pas
pourquoi pas un fou n'importe quoi je
remonte à 2007 avant ces partis dans
n'importe quoi hélas à 3 heures tu
allais pas qui est ce de sorties tels
maxime dans le chat s'était très bien
quoi
c'était très marrant mais où il va qui
j'aime bien quand il débarque très tard
car oui le tf 1 2
il faut bien que je connaisse les règles
pour le prochain stringer il est content
il serait bien non en fait il m'a
expliqué ce qu'il faisait en fait ils
laissent le stream ouvert il regarde pas
vraiment ils travaillent jour et
sensibilisation 6 il a le truc ouvert à
côté et il attend qu'il se passe un peu
quelque chose et là il arrive pas et
liège où il est sur le coup ça arrive
c'est un petit pas qui est si tu mets un
petit truc il repart quoi y attend quoi
unis s'attendent à 1 min 10 hockey est
un coaching qui arrive enfin on sait pas
quoi tu tout cas moi de temps en temps
c'est le cas de beaucoup de joueurs je
pense oui et c'est ça qui est il est là
sans être là que nancy quelques dames
français cette dame français 750 soit
tous les nations mais bon mé lé tour qui
débat a débarqué quoi bah ouais puis
retour posé ma chance
écoute je serai pas mécontent dans le
drame si vous faites ça me prend g7 ou
g8 et ça va faire mal
d'ailleurs ils le provoquent chaque
levier à clarifier la même chose qu'à
peu près tout le monde fait ça blesse
ouvert ils attendent qu'il ya un truc
quoi ce truc bas d'ailleurs est fière
quand c'est devenu marrant il était déjà
trop 2h30 du matin
bizarrement le chat et revenir actif
tout d'un coup qu'on avait plein jour
des excuses en train de dormir ou quoi
et à tout d'un coup pas mais une partie
mythique jeu pour être montrées
extraordinaire ça a réveillé tout le
monde à 2h30 du matin qui me défonce à
chaque fois et vent et vendre au
barbossa je passe tu connais non mais
ouais mais en fait une défonce tout le
temps quoi enfin vraiment mais il
panique à chaque fois que tu attaques
sont rois à la fin comme un fou
donc tu sais comment faire pour non mais
bon du coup il a une pièce de plus ses
coups de poing en gagnant puis chevalier
trucs sur son roi quoi mais même pas
grand chose en fait mais si je sais pas
il panique et c'est marrant quoi face
marrant il est toujours à plus 8 quoi et
puis tout d'un coup pour lui c'est
autrement il ne sera plus temps zazie
rui je devrais appeler notre manu
ferraille le bas assez souvent
est ce que ce sont les champions du
monde de classiques en 968 pas et
champion du monde de 960 g10 jeu
classique mais à la petite finale
non seulement des qui peut il faible
mais bien je pensais 5tourcoing f4 et
les deux pions en l'air et sur qui elle
prend ainsi soin bessette
tu as tour des huit il veut qu'ils
avaient pensé 5tourcoing f4 tour prend
des huit prises des limites et est
reprise à ses parts dans d'autres pays
s'y sont fait coincer dame prend des six
suspense juste de l'apprendre à quatre
là quand même je pense tu penses ce
qu'aime un pion bon je le prendrais lee
byrne de la dame tranquille
8 cette attaque est donc juste fallu est
il contre attaque la dent mais ça il va
gagner facilement la simple non plus
pour 1 voix il reprend le large
redevienne normal je pouvais du suc
remous
il ya vraiment mal joueurs m'ont donné
un ca de 6 je pense qu'il veut c'est
bien la notice brevet c'est aussi cet
effet non non mais 5 mais j'ai en fait
un f6 un jour mais adam prémices
cette affaire d'âme le sydam g4 ouais
ouais vous dame au 6e tour des huit
totalement faire libérer à tatouille
affaire d'âme ses six pour être bien
sûrs et six points ce week end
non on n'est pas bien sûr mais pas bien
sûr elle a enfin bon jour ab sat procès
6 ou 7 6 4 et 5
et sa part hervé 5
tchao pantin il a besoin
il défend vraiment bien quand même faut
vraiment le souligner je trouve vraiment
un excellent défenseur voir c'est fini
mais mais c'est pas une qualité que
j'allais bien
oui oui on va t'il fait il ya défendre
et défendre on va dire en fait ils te
défends de la merde pendant longtemps
oui il est mal mais en fait j'aime bien
les défenseurs un peu moins bien et qui
était ce pas de chance de gain ouais je
sais rien car yakine tu préfères ouais
voilà ça c'est vraiment de la vraie
défense l'axé de la défense internet moi
j'ai envie de dire c'est qu'en fait je
te fais chier en blitz apte à jouer un
truc au choix - 12 est juste je te la
fait jouer dans cinquante coups et tu
trompes tu vas pas gagné mais en fait
c'est déjà trop tard soit sauvée en fait
on va dire si courte que cannes sérieux
ouais mais là ça fait plus cinq et ça y
est on commence enfin à être bien sûr
qu'il ya un joueur plus fort que l'autre
je commence à m'inquiéter donc qu'est ce
que c'est il demanderait qu'un week-end
dans cette finale qui est sympa car ce n
est un gros défenseur havas carlson mais
carsen en fait c'est un gros toi seule
goutte rousse mais défense en finale
deux tours par exemple tu vois on
l'avait bien vu à dans sa partie contre
les bonnes c'est pas son point fort
après il défend bien évidemment mais
c'est pas là son point le plus fort quoi
y'a mieux que lui après il doit être top
5 mondial sans aucun problème mais après
quand même sa série de 120 partis sans
défaite
non mais on aime aussi les jeux en des
bons mecs
il a fait que les taux de tournois par
banques étaient trois parties intercom
norvégien mer mais c'était que des tops
tournoi tout le reste sinon ouais c'est
le patron un non en fait je pensais que
des travaux jusqu'à 200 partis qu'en fin
en fait je voyais pas trop comment elle
avait gardé ta vraie c'est l'impression
qu'il a fait exprès enfin pas exprès
mais tu as l'impression qu'il en voyait
vraiment toi toutes les parties quoi
ouais ok moi c'est bien pour lui de pas
ça te fait déjouer quand je vous sers
toi tu veux plus perdre mais du coup tu
joue peut-être plus pour gagner non plus
alors que lui non dit le juge
normalement aux échecs y arriver savard
gars qui l'a ratée d'assez simple il a
raté à peu prend b2 tour b info f6 ça
commence à déjouer des deux côtés
mais dingemans en partie la talk ces
trucs aussi il en a fait deux d'ailleurs
de très longues deux fois au moins 90
avec un style intéressant mais bon après
les mecs avaient juste peur de lui quoi
dans metal cette impression puis jouer
vite talent aussi
j'ai lu sa biographie
dernièrement en fait ils pensaient que
faty calculez bien il savait que ces
trucs était fondamentalement pas
forcément correct mais il pensait qu'en
puissent s'y jouer vite ces trucs du
clumeq a pas le temps de surtemps et ans
de pression et du coup comme il sait que
et mais en fait quand tu as ces analyses
iwuy bombe à la machin et puis en fait
il se dit ah mais là en fait face juste
et une partie en tête
oui sacrifie une pièce machin en fait il
est ok mais au pire j'ai cette variante
et rentre dans une finale où il va
réussir à finir dans un tour vous contre
tours en groupe au pire edit je vais la
défendre en fait ça là non mais tu te
calcule un truc un peu chaud il se voit
une porte de sortie si jamais dans une
intrigue il va défendre mais du coup en
fait ils te rentrer là dedans très vite
quoi et puis après ils vont y voit quoi
fin suivant ce qui calcule pendant sur
ton temps quoi mais ces faillites va
être très dur à jouer en réalité club je
te mets tout tempo dans ta gueule je te
sacrifies le truc citerons pas un peu ou
construits et pas très correct je vais
te faire un petit jeu de défendre une
finale pas grave je sais faire et puis
si ça se passe bien et tu vas tomber
comme une merde quoi
non mais faut que tu fasses en fait
n'était pas champion du monde par hasard
ouais j'ai 4 prépare toi quoi
taipei dit j'ai croisé talons venir 185
à montpellier pour les candidats il
fumer clope sur clope et avec beaucoup
d'humour
ouais ça doit être un gars marrant
talent ne sont pas tous les soirs avec
l'une des anecdotes vous devez pas
t'ennuyer quoi
ça devait être un bon vivant j'ai
toujours su
un coureur de jupons aussi ah oui ah bah
oui
non ils avaient affaire d'être un gars
coup le talent est excellent buteur
[Musique]
si ça ça le rend plus sympa mais l'autre
des centres autour des 4
tour de cup ce bien moi tu prends et sur
par là bas après quoi
il est beau joueur dans les années 60 70
fischer talent non membres est engagée
après je sais pas si on les voit parce
qu'avec des yeux un trait arrive mais
tous les mêmes des clients et où cos
était bien larsen galère keller nul ce
n'était pas ma force était pas un tata
steel qui fait rêver mais ses propres
frais je pense est beaucoup moins forte
que ce qu'on a maintenant montrer qu'un
prof qui arrive bah ouais c'est sympa je
crois que c'était moins fort en fait et
du coup ça a été des plus belles parties
fait c'est je pense c'est vraiment ça le
truc tu as des teams and comme ça qu'ils
t'ont voyait elle écorche n'a réussi
après un bac marche mais il a été
pendant plein de jeunes décennies on
sait pas trop où je sais ils bloquent
les colonnes de tout bouffer mais même
le nejm et 10 nov dont on a parlé qui
était quand même en dessous et tout ça
quand tu relis le livre de talent et
tout en fait il était hyper respecté et
très beaux jours d'attaquer tout fin ça
l'empêché autour des 4 as et du coup il
vient faire un regard évalue férois bien
au roi sa mort avait deux tours c'est
torse 4 marois les droits c'est ce
prophète emporte droits d'auteur dont
trois auraient fouillé partout où ils
enlèveront f2 fall il a trop de choix
tout va des 300 chats il a eu il a eu un
trou d'air en fait étonnant
bah ça trop raison à des concentrations
vêtements ouais trop facile c'était trop
facile et la bayard est plus que 13
minutes il a pris six points
oui enfin il se passe qui est ce qu'on
attendait quoi mais il ya eu ce passage
marans où il caffè il faisait n'importe
quoi mes cheveux pourquoi il kiffe
tellement juste là comme ça donne c'est
déjà trop tôt dans le match s'était
déroulé paris hb car c'était ça j'ai en
fait t'es quand même pas obligé de sueur
qui est des cadres de sortir en tête
foix iv vous ces cartes a dit cook en
guise
je commençais par b 4 et enfin tu peux
changer de partout quoi etc avec les
moyens qu elle qui a toujours des années
50 centres pour être à niveau
actuellement bas à tous je pense pas
pourquoi pas où en est-on sein mais il
n'y a pas de raison qu'il soit
intrinsèquement moins fort justes ils
sont pas du tout au niveau au niveau
théorique tout ça est vrai que parce que
leur retard qui voit ainsi l'évolution
des styles de jeu
c'est en fait dans les échecs mais déjà
à l'époque c'est un peu compris ça mais
au début en fait tout ce qui était
stratégique ça faisait vraiment avant le
dynamisme
ja rule avions doublé très grave je vais
m'isoler supergrave marque en fait c'est
pas grave on palabre ça peut être faible
ou pas faible et pour ce qui se passe
autour
mais ça on l'a très bien compris
maintenant il ya eu une évolution avec
ça sur trois et 70 plus l'apport des
ordis vraiment révolutionné et donc ses
mails et 50 pour être juste qu'ils se
remettent en phase avec sa donc qui
pourra le faire que pourra pas le faire
etc
mais après en termes de puissance de
calcul dos quand ce qu'ils ont apporté
dans le jeu ils ont dû défricher un
territoire dit à inventer des trucs
c'était brillant s'il faisait donc je
commençais années 60
je vois pas trop moins fort mais j'ai
pas de fin c'est toujours dur va te dire
c'est comme si on te dit c'est ce que
vient me voir aujourd'hui pourra
rivaliser avec nadal
satoru c'est pas un président barack est
en fait la mise en place est très
édifiant bracket
ben pas l'entraînement un moment bien
sûr si là il jouait alors niveau de
l'époque et maintenant natale de défense
mais si tu prends un jeune borg qui a 15
ans qu'il entraîne et quand il a 25 ans
il va jouer bas enfin voilà bah tu
pourras jamais répondre à ce genre de
questions et inversement ne pas savoir
c'est un mec très fort aujourd'hui a été
très fort à l'autre est pas leur époque
fatima carlson en norvège qui a accès à
0 entraîneur machin il n'y a pas
vraiment de tournoi est ce qu'il va
vraiment devenir fort on n'en sait rien
j'avais josé chef met donc c'est
toujours dur mais quels efforts
maintenant ils sont forts tout le monde
est forte
non mais oui c'est pas tout à fait de
même je sais pas tout à fait c'est
complètement différent mais j'aimais
bien ton truc de dire que le vélo à
l'époque en fait vu l'inflation machin
et ça vaut le même locaux aujourd'hui
ouais bon je sais pas je suis une idée
parmi d'autres
je suis pas sûr de ce que je dis
d'efforts mais après celui qui a mis le
plus d'écart en terme de niveau quand
ils ont passé les parties à l'ordi et
l'écart est vraiment finale ces six
chars mais de très très loin tee shirts
des fours fischer je sais plus les trucs
de quatre sacs en titre le font les
autres à une toute petite différence
puis quand affichant le truc sort de
l'écran quoi tellement ça va au tu vois
même plus quoi faire
les autres sont heureusement descendu en
bas et lui ont fait du vélo ça on sait
en fait ça se voit du coup que celui qui
a été vraiment le cas mais le plus
d'écart sur le numéro 2 mondial c'est
fischer neither défenseur
non mais bon on mettre deux fois 6 0
c'est pas un accident parce que ça
jouait en face à hazard larsson s'est
vraiment pas un mauvais état ema neuf
non plus d'ailleurs je pense moins forte
qu en scène que personne mais
c'est déjà costaud pas très malin et
mais la dame avait plus ou moins
fermeture une piastre ont poussé 4,4 g
s'inquiète encore c4 mais tu perds 25
c'est pas une pièce un pion et web est
encore donc sales draps oui donc time
and off qui a perdu en quarts de finale
6 0
c'était déjà énorme et il remet 6 0 en
demi contre larsson après la veillée
mishara petrossian ici quand même non
ouais mais c'était plus serré que ça en
fait contre des pressions s'étaient
serrés pour six parties il était à 3 3
je crois pas c'est certain
et après ces tâches et en fin de match
un peu comme si je disais sur le live
d'hier je suis convaincu que que fisher
enfin truc émerger des agressions et
live mais on souccot pas ce qui en fait
qui fait qu'on sait pas si c'est parce
qu'ils étaient vraiment moins fort que
fisher enfin jean suivant on en est sûr
nassau suite les perform et feignant
hyper fort avec leur forme mais pas sur
l'or que cheikh fisher et travailler oui
c'est un énorme bosseur
enfin pour exécuter en fait c est que ce
lot de coucher avec les échecs tout tout
tout le temps quoi il a vu une partie de
moins dans le match mais en fait ça lui
a donné tellement davantage
psychologique de pas jouer cette partie
non mais ce qu'il faut c'est facile à
dire avec le recul injuste il voulait
voulu jouer royal mais il a accepté de
s'était pas loyers en tapissant il est
ici mis en infériorité psychologique ou
je sais pas quoi
pas rien et qu'il aurait pas quand même
perdu une fille sur cet énorme mais se
passe t'il pas de truc c'est qu'avant ce
match n'est jamais tu sais quand même ce
qu'ils aiment bien un truc quoi fin
non mais c'est pas du coup je trouve que
c'est un peu dommage que les gens ont eu
beau dans cette histoire là ils te
retiennent un espace qui perd et
peinture et du coup ils épaves 27 ans
les champions du monde qu'on cite le
moins comme étant très fort parce qu'ils
bas je trouve que c'est enfin je
rangerai déjà parler j'en reparle
maintenant mais je trouve que c'est un
peu injuste envers ce parce qu'ils n'ont
mais en fait c'est clair fischer varin
serait pour lui puisque en fait le buzz
cette fois que leur jeu de sa vie
c'était vous qui l'emploie après il est
allé chercher chez pas qui ou quoi et
c'est pas que pour faire un recueil vol
de 72 c'était que je pense que spéciale
avec lui annonce est un c'est un gros
gros joueurs espace qui réussit un beau
jardin très complet mais les plus
torrides et gambit roi des siennes fermé
tout ça c'était pas que le style plan
plan c'est un grand joueur mais fisher a
gaffé la première partie basse à ce
besoin
on sent jamais en fait c'est un oui
c'est pas bon ce qu'il a fait dans cette
source n'était pas perdre ouais et la
fête chez post 1 je sais qu'on ne puisse
pas savoir en fait il a raison ça me
paraît tellement impossible d'oublier g3
non mais il n'a pas oublié
enfin c'est sur c'est peut-être qu'ils
jouaient déjà pour le gain facile oui tu
vas tu auras une pièce compte deux pions
sheppard est pas si sûr c'est un truc
comme ça c'est mal joué
ça c'est sûr mais il n'a pas pu obliger
j'ai du mal à appeler ça genre il a
gaffé en mode
il a fait enfin c'est pas une en oublie
ou quoi en fait c'est une gap vont enfin
c'est une erreur volontaire à face est
une erreur et il a mal un nom de
lucidité vaches pas que ça mais j'ai
trois faillites à vue s'ils n'étaient
pas nés oui déjà ça c'est quoi la
différence entre ouverture ce n'est
ouverte à ces miss fermé je crois que
ces dépositions suivant si elles sont un
peu fermé après 4 ou des 4 je me
rappelle plus jamais ça
c'était en fait d'avoir vraiment
différence parce que le verre à moitié
plein ou été vite mais après tout ça
pour dire que que oui c'est pas faim moi
j'aime pas appeler ça une gaffe dans le
sens où gaffe pour moi c'est vraiment
quand d'irakia oublier en fait je vois
tu veux être à ma budget 3 qui merde
yaya toure âge fait une gaffe
donc c'est mieux ou versé sur e4 tout
sauf 5 et sami fermé sur des cats tout
sauf des zones ouest devils appellation
non mais c'est vrai que ça peut être
bizarre tu es les gens ils peuvent se
dire que c'est même nous on ne sait pas
trop trop juste ni ouverte ni fermée fin
aux hasards quoi pas une chanson sognu
versé aux quatre parties ouvertes sur
quatre ans fait donc soumis quelque
chose soit 15 m pourquoi mais au fait
pourquoi ce qu'aurait dit il il a joué
au 3 mai 4,5 s'est ouvert et le reste
c'est celui marine chilienne ces semi
ouvert voilà je pense métier de fermer
parce que c'est celui ouvert cette
limite n'est pas toi ici semi-ouvert
risque mais on dirait que ces semi
fermée mais alors là d'un faux nom c'est
complètement
nous on dirait d'une française que c'est
une position fermée et d'une sicilienne
c'est une position semi fermée et alors
que non pas du tout c'est de position
semi ouverte eu en fait ça veut rien
dire ce truc là c'est non mais en fait
c'est pas la qualité de la position et
12 juin c'est comme le godet qu en fait
un mot oui c'est la motion peut être
complètement fermée et que ce soit
pourtant une partie ouverte
georges fait ou 85 g après il ya des
quatre des cinq fin des cadres d ici le
dessin est à un moment et c5 des noirs
et elles sont toutes bloquées de galles
là c'est une partie ouverte
alors c'est quoi ton cher matin mais
c'est ouvert
voilà donc c'est pas présent parle pas
de la position mais c'est une
classification des ouvertures qui n'a
rien à voir avec la pulsion présentement
sur le chic et ce qui est marrant c'est
qu'on parle aussi dans la position
présentement sur l'échiquier dit c'est
une position ferme et où une position
ouverte en parlant fondamentalement de
la position genre et vaut avoir une
position ouverte pour les fous les
cavaliers mes positions vertes peut
venir d'une ouverture fabricio fermer
quoi enfin du coup ils fouillent sur
l'horaire mais peut être ouverte
exactement c'est compliqué tout ça ça
c'est les positions trop dinger comme
dit jeudi
c'est compliqué j'étais sûr qu'il allait
faire ça est fou des quatre pour bien
échangé mais bon après il a six points
d'avancé et là maintenant c'est normal
il reste combien de temps il reste 2 35
normalement il y aura une partie de plus
romain c'est comme la bonne nouvelle
jusqu'à 6-6 pas drôle très heureux
prison passant h3 bref caprock et 5 et
se barrer de 5 à masquer 8 ça peut ça
c'est le genre de fourchette qui peuvent
passer d'abord mais surtout quand ils
constatent épuisé un peu au bout d'un
moment
mais c'est là sur la huitième elle est
chiante à la ceux qui pensent pas
toujours tampon des soldes ça peut faire
un truc pareil la finale d'options jeu
poche deux jours m wade doit calculer sa
valeur dit je vois que ça
iman au numéro un j'avais pas calculé -
s'étaient tues tige
ça va faire plus cette dame héros actifs
sains pourtant ils appellent ça
al'avantage des espaces en finale dans
les bouquins de cours des quatre ou six
tutoriel un coup d'attendre
c'est incorrect à pau et de fermes
j'aime bien fixer d'autres humains
peut-être tu l'enlèves des coups
d'attentats lui réussit non mais sinon
j'ai 5
enfin j'essaie de faire tout autant d'un
côté tu peux faire v3 en espérant qu'il
fasse ses 5 pour pouvoir plus rapidement
battu pour tout bien réfléchi calcul
voilà fait bien sûr sans rigoler la fois
être bien sûr il a bien calculé
parce qu'en venant il enchaîne
opposition à distance
il re calcul bien comme il faut bonsoir
j'ai cinq jours où les c5 c'est pas mal
foutu pour cette avancée avant de
recourir l'autre côté 25 secondes dans
la cadence à tête d'être la dernière
femme maintenant alors didonne nul
aurait fait absolument faire ses cinq
départs c'est logique c'est ça mais bon
en fait c'est facile à dire logique pas
logique c'est que du calcul des finales
de pions mais en soit huit ans vit dans
la traitons pions le plus impossible
parce que quand tu vas faire g53 prend
courir avec trois énormes et vous faire
de contre jeu de l'autre côté ça va être
une course en main c'est à la dernière
partie à tyson a non au contraire
déception en fait tu comment paroisse
g73 f5 et la protéine ska de retard est
terrible mais oui c'est que du calcul là
pour la paix mais bon si on veut pas
calculer autant faire un truc logique et
s'avance et l'option pièce mais là ça
paraît tellement gagnant quand même
vision
h6 y avait acheté ce qu'ils gagnent
c'est terrible d'avoir raté ça j'avais
cherché à neutre ouais mais en fait si
serrés et lui-même sans ordi je gagnais
un signe les chèques oui du coup gagnant
attend en fait tu ya une opposition
droite c'est trop moche hein continue
white 7 et en freinant il devrait venir
angers 6 à la mi temps de retard il a
juste pas chercher en fait ouais ouais
bah ça fait plus 6 donc match défunt la
wii c'est déjà pierre honnêtement la vue
un peu plus le suspense prévu ce que ce
soit vraiment ces failles c'est un
moment donné c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment est étrange
bah ouais je sais pas pourquoi comment
ben non non c'est assez étrange question
on n'y peut rien c'est voir se posent
aux stéphanois message en 3d cette compo
bon ouais bah écoutes je pas combien
et on dit je jure que baky regrette de
ne pas l'avoir commenter celle-là celui
là bah oui maximin avec maxime il était
sur la plus belle affiche un tel match
maxime il avait la pudeur mais coûte
franchement c'est pas si mal
maintenant grâce aux c'est pas si mal
sait pas non plus si bien mais ça match
du premier tour on peut pas non plus
voir un choc énorme direct en réalité on
a eu beaucoup de chance avec le match de
mercredi est le fil rouge a fait le 7
mai que je suis content parce que je
l'avais cochée comme plus beaux matchs
quand on chasse comme m'a dit on prend
un maxime pour un match commenté un
match du premier tour
moi j'aurais dit fedoseyev firoud déjà
plus beau match que j'avais sélectionné
imminent fin quand même karl scène par à
mme carlsson ce sera aussi un trou un
carnage
barrett c'est comme les matchs de
premier tour quant à nadal mafate et
comptant droit nadal mais en fait on
peut être 6 2 6 1 6 0
donc en valais depuis y est il y aura
aucun enjeu
c'est mieux de voir un gouffre incinère
en fait dit des trompes détrompe-toi des
trois mois voyez ce que j'avais dit aux
estivales mais à détrompe toi
non mais après ça dépend si parfois
quand tu t'es allé voir l' us open
j'étais très content de le voir nadal
rogers pourra jouer bon ils ont mis
trois sets 0 c'était des carnages mais
j'étais content de les voir parce que je
les vois pas tous les jours mais quand
tu vois 150 matches à l'année de carlson
si tu as le choix je préférerais un
match un peu serré un peu en dessous
genre tu mets un cas qui m'irrite choc
je dis juste un truc comme ça je trouve
ça mieux avoir que tu cap scène par
hamouma après en plus fier ou déjà fait
2 cfl avantage c'est que les styles de
jeu était exceptionnel voilà pour un
match de reprise y est c'est plus serré
c'est sympa et c'est ce qui est fait
c'est excellent équivalente de joueurs
qui jouent service volée en beats
apprend longue durée un peu différemment
méambly de c'est comme si
faites moi un carré scène par am c'était
un genre de jeu peut apparemment pas
qu'un joueur de tennis mais ça à
l'ancienne un genre de corée déjà en
fête est en fait un lot tu as tout faux
dans le filet pendant pas tu te bats des
photos guinée à vos points mais j'ai
gagné un jeu où tu va galérer et puis tu
te faire de france et d'ailleurs je
regrette je regrette vraiment les matchs
de terre battue à l'ancienne on a de
moins en moins sa niche de partout très
bon en fait ils ont tellement eu peur
ils ont tellement uniformiser toutes les
surfaces que même si elle est différente
c'est quand même plus comme avant où et
avec celui derrière c'est dommage mais
g20 peut être qu'ils ont pensé que
c'était bien pour pour l'audience
après ça elle saigne enfin la vajol ils
ont des très bons résultats donc c'est
que ça marche bien mais moi ça me manque
un peu les matchs vraiment à l'ancienne
la non mais que le gazon ça fuse que
tarbes battu soit lente et puis que du
reboot fais comme tu veux un peu plus
rapide un peu plus lent tu vois des gens
maintenant le droit le plus rapide c'est
l'australien alors que de barrer grand
chelem - ouais alors que de base sa
femme était wimbledon par tradition
pendant pendant des décennies maintenant
et après sur le circuit à l'année a
peut-être des toiles plus rapide mais il
ya les raquettes aussi vrais qu'ils ont
beaucoup changé de choses on met tout a
changé le débat
j'imagine tout pourrait utilement dagail
ce qu'ils en pensent s'il est content
lui aussi préféré que lui il aime bien
défendre après donc non mais parce
qu'ils arrangent ligue 2 en tant que
joueur perso mais qu'ils en pensent
s'ils savaient plus de charme si
finalement c'est une évolution logique
et que c'est bien comme ça que voilà en
tout cas d'après d'après ce que je pense
comprendre c'est que même quand on
regarde un match on comprend rien en
fait je suis on regarde oui comprendre
ce qui se passe en fait en fait moi je
suis un petit cherche à comprendre aux
joueurs entendent spectateurs mais comme
un match de foot j'en veux ça fait 30
ans gérante du foot mais
de plus dire j'ai pas la finale c'est
exactement de comprendre tout dans ce
court ça j'aurais bien voulu rencontrer
un entraîneur juste pour discuter pour
un an genre tu as tu passé une soirée à
discuter avec n'importe quoi st-gall qui
accourent cubain qui tu veux un peu
importe quand même c'est un peu comme
aux échecs des fois moi je vois dans le
chat quand je perds contre un gars tu
vois pas ce qu il me domine dans un truc
doit une pourquoi tu change pas mais en
fait si tu changes de ce que tu joues
date est même pire face à un monde et
quand un gars qui est plus fort que toi
petit domina globalement et tu vas dans
un endroit où tu penses par les
meilleures chances et d'art des fois
quand tu changes c'est encore pire en
fait passer à quelqu'un qui peut fort
que toi en tactique en finale 20 de
partout tu as ton jeu de ton mieux c'est
quoi des fois tu as l'impression que il
retourne pas son service quand il met
sur le revers mais en fait tu as tu peux
pas en fait pincer tu fais pas exprès
quoi george est pure à des matchs de
rogers où tu dis c'est pas possible de
sortir autant de revers quoi fin c'est
impossible à un moment donné tu dis mais
mais d'autres pilotes et son effet je
sais on n'a pas été dans sa situation
parce que si tu dois dire ok si je
remets un truc lambda en fait façon je
le fais défoncer donc j'ai pas eu peur
juste ça marche jamais quoi et au final
qui peut rien ça paraît complètement
quand tu regarde à la télé mais en fait
ce qu'ils émettraient tout dans le
courbe en fait atteint reverra tiens je
te remets un livre dans le dans le coin
opposé series va le chercher
et du coup tu es obligé de tenter un
truc et tu le rates c'est tout quoi non
mais oui mais chez toi son côté hyper
intéressant tactiquement et donc le
tennis vous êtes laruns je pense que
quand tu es sur le terrain tu ressens le
truc où as tu prends davantage qu'elles
courent mer de l'autre quel schéma de
jeu tu donnes mettre en place est ok et
le foot ça très intéressant aussi dans
l'alignement dans le marquage dans
l'animation
même les combinaisons a travaillé pour
les coups de pied arrêtés comme ça moi
je sais pas j'ai pas la prétention de
capter tous enfin là ça va commencer ce
soir quand je regarde mais je sais pas
pas la finesse d'analysé vers en détail
au sport compliqué ici tu te rends pas
compte quand tu regarde de loin et moi
je comprends que c'est compliqué mais je
comprends pas tout ce qui se passe en
plus c'est le rugby c'est hyper
compliqué en fait d'un mas de
combinaisons tu dois jouer au près au
large machin suivant les équipes 1 c'est
très compliqué même des fois tu vois des
gars qui avance en fait tu dis oui le
gars est très fort il avance sur tous
les impacts tout cas elle en fait un
mythe juste sur les impacts
parce que tu as le demi de mêlée qui a
plein d'options et que du coup tu as il
est toujours dans le bon tu vois dans le
bloc de course ou quoi mais tu mettrais
un mauvais demi de mêlée une mauvaise
stratégie le mec en fait ils feraient
ils reculeraient trois mètres à chaque
impact
toi tu fais ce que je veux dire mais
aussi avancé dans des impacts parce que
tu es dans la bonne situation et parce
que tes équipiers avance aussi ou enfin
c'est pas du tout débile où il tue cours
et tu vas tout le temps avance et quoi
pas du tout c'est moi je pense que tous
les sports sont beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'on ne le pense mais je pense va c'est
pas même la boxe tu te dis oui c'est
devait constater sur la gueule
oui mais bon on va regarder en détail
c'est comme diriger que c'est avec un
objet des bouts de bois
chapron peuls avaient besoin tian les
échecs c'est pas si compliqué que je
dirais que j'ai à vous de voir mais du
coup on fait des autres sports ils sont
regardables plus facilement parce que
t'as pas besoin de comprendre tous ces
trucs là pour les regarder alors que les
échecs si ça tu peux regarder sans trop
comprendre et ça reprend et qu'elle
allait blanc ce qui leur fait un air
france on écossaise qui est parce que
c'est le marché de toner allez il faut
qu'ils gagnent fou qui gagna les trois
quatre parties d'affilée et ça peut le
ca
peut-être cette fuite plutôt pour gagner
ce match du coup il doit y avoir il ya
combien de
payera plus tard si ce n'est pas
mathématique fondée par encore
détrompe-toi d'en-cas écoute ça joue
sajou voilà un avant goût que je peux
comprendre c'est qu'il est blanc espère
un jour valoriser leurs trois condamnés
de droit
donc tu juges pour un kit avantages des
structures mais après ça reste assez
solide il ya encore pas mal de pièces
sur l'échiquier
tant que c'est pas une finale de roi ou
quoi au final très simple c'est un peu
anecdotique mais tu as un projet d'
échange de pièces côté blanc tu as rôti
de veau qui est pas content il n'y a que
30 minutes ce dernier fasse et pas un
set 1 c'est un segment ouais enfin plus
un mais du coup c'est le segment il ya
le plus de parties théoriquement non
j'avais le temps de tromper sort qui
sera le plus fort bon là ça a l'air
d'aller pour les deux joueurs peut-être
un petit avantage blanc quand même mais
les pions h doublé il bloque bien failli
bloc de pions en fait je pense non mais
je sais pas ce qu'il choisirait voit
dans les blanches pour ses cartes
blanches mais je veux penser à prendre
des singles giro il me tape ça craint
son père h5 ou quoi il y voit la fatigue
il a même fait ce choix mais oui ça fait
aucun doute je lancerai mieux après ce
que s'ils gagnent on peut mieux c'est
sûr car c'est la seule cadence où il a
pas moins de deux lots à tous et aura
fait enfin hockey et 4 8 points de moins
mais j'ai envie de dire c'est pas une
grand chose n'ont pas grand chose à
faire à 17
ça défend bien
du loupé quelque chose actuellement ça
partait très bien aller de mon passé les
nanterriens aura été loin et là il tout
bloquer il prend le pion oui mais je
crois qu'en fait il peut prendre un
bateau le prendre mais c'est un gros
point fort en fait nous on a peur parce
qu'on est nul et que du coup on a du mal
à jouer des trucs pratiques mais en fait
le qui sont forts comme ils sont carré
d'as qui a tué 15 les matchs tu vois que
tu vois que rien mais rien ne prouve en
faire même aléatoire non mais tu te
payes tour des quatre oui c'est ça
attendez 4 et il va te mettre le roi
henri iv et il va faire des cinq ça tu
prends une enfilade du zambien enfin une
à huy une cloison ormeaux tes vrais ne
pas jouer quoi là tu as comme ça c'est
avec les bons objets 3d paris deux
problèmes à chrome os pour les hausses
probables hausses j'ai même problème
hausse
c'est vraiment génial service d'ordre
ça fait plus cette année
il reste encore une petite chance mon
fab
il a gagné elle est trop fort un avait
pronostiqué +10 écoute ça pourrait ça
pourrait passer mais si tu imagines
comme la différence de niveau avec ce
qui s'est vraiment et à un moment donné
et malgré tout ils gagnent très
facilement au final il a su se relever
quand il fallait ouais non mais je n'ai
pas été inquiet d'un truc s'élevait deux
fois ou quoi il y avait il y avait un
truc en fait
ça sonnait à la porte le chat miaulait
ça ouais ouais le chat et du coup il
fait pas ça l'a complètement
déstabilisée
les images ici facile nous détrompe toi
je n'ai pas besoin d'être concentré j'ai
toujours su
ouais non je sais pas je sais pas ce qui
lui est arrivé mais oui il ya quelque
chose qui l'a sorti du match aller il
fait pas une grande partie une nouvelle
fois non ouais bah ouais c'est qu'il a
perdu un peu le pion de 5 pour pas grand
chose
donc là forcément il souffre nature mois
donc bel avantage noir bref à faire
fructifier tout ça mais ça à faire le
taf ce qui sut il a les doigts dans
l'est à fond quoi c'est génial c'est
terrible d'être dans les narines
ouais carrément ouais ouais mais là
c'est c'est terrible mais bon à force
oublie qu'il ya les caméras et où il est
tranquille chez lui c'est terrible je me
sens qu'il récupère russie ce nom sans
regarder non mais c'est dur à la fin aux
îlots match est fini mais bon il peut
être un bien fini mais il gagne même le
flanc enfin tous et toutes des 700
objets lecavalier en l'air et tout en
les re est devenu un ghetto ouais bah je
crois que lé plus dit son hôte cette
annonce mauvaise nouvelle que quand je
t'ai dit qu'il aurait dit parti c'est le
positif enfin c'est vraiment le max le
minimum je veux dire normalement il ya
plus neuf parties que 10 kw à 8 9 et 6
la gagner les doigts dans le nez
[Rires]
bah oui feno l'entrejeu le ss pour voir
ça n'est pas grave de faire la deuxième
mi temps peut-être à motion c'était il
ya déjà 4 0 tu vois là la deuxième tu
vas pas la rater un puisqu'il reste
l' avantage là c'est que tu sais combien
de matches durs de temps il y aura pas
de prolongations ici voilà en plus le
truc c'est qu'il fait durer la partie
alors évidemment il s'en fiche parce
qu'il sait qu'il a perdu mais je veux
dire par là que la partie est du genre
bien comme il faut quoi pour qui ne
vient pas dit partie scolaire est
combien reste 22 minutes trente deux
parties il faut quatre victoires partis
en moyenne un peu moins
ouais 3 45 parties devraient donc en
gros ça fait 9
ça fait neuf ans qu'on a deux qui sont
joués il en reste sept à huit points
d'écart problèmes risquent bien un truc
marrant que fait ben à qui je sais pas
pourquoi je peux citer la raison en fait
ces cinq dix et sinko étudiants français
mais c'est aussi une qu il est très
heureux
ces cinq seul coup qui inclut en
espagnol c'est signe qu'on aurait très
content je sais pas pourquoi c'est si à
l'époque avec maso on avait bien vous
avez connu enfin par l'espagnol comme on
pouvait à quoi les têtes c'est un mot
castet de mazo je vois pas ce qu'il y'a
que c'est ici une qu en fait tu dessines
gones n'ont pas bien envie de réussir
une cause aussi coiffe un oui mais bon
je sais ça et là c'est ici une coiffe à
duras et elle le sait sinko la tête
salut par kouakou particulier classé
signe que peut-être les libérations c5
comme c'est un joueur des disques de
granby dame de machin non pas que ce
sein que ça respire que c'est pas juste
un coup l'on voit la ccim qu'aux témoins
poupe en tant que joueur de cela tu vois
le cecim qu il fait plaisir
moi qui joue slave karo kann si juste à
sciences po et simcoe bim dans ta gueule
bien joué il a fait vite même filer dos
à deux fils commerce et quattro pas
propres problèmes osseux de partout mais
bon ça à promettre des baux quarts de
finale en tout cas parce que les matches
à partir des quarts vont être serré de
partout là tous les meilleurs se
qualifier même georges même georges
mais georges il joue plus trop sur un
terrain je sais pas comment ça se passe
avec son taf peut-être et tout parce que
ça lui c'est un joueur amateur georges
entre guillemets il a un travail après
c'est un énorme joueur mais je le vois
sur internet et où il un peu disparu il
fait quoi comme boulot et je sais plus
mais c'est dommage que c'est quelqu'un
que j'appréciais non mais tu vois il me
bat mais s'il est relou mais notre coeur
l'américain bunge avait un respect enfin
j'aimais bien joué contre lui parce que
c'est un saint mais l'adversaire qua non
puis c'est un bel adversaire pas que tu
quand tu gagnes une partie contre
meilleur tu sais que tu as fait une
grosse game parce que le gars est
insupportable même pas tu joues pour
avoir des adversaires comme ça je veux
pas que pour jeu des coachings bon c'est
quand même un petit peu de kôji cas et
ne met pas trop trop il va lui faire un
petit saut à 5
donc les deux
ouais et cette fois ci et du coup le
fait je sais pas pourquoi il l'est
continue c'est par ce bon baladeur pour
que je suis je parle pour qu'ils
abandonnent mais tu as quand va t en et
moins tu en as marre fait ouais c'est
une variante pas si nuls en fait pas si
moi non plus je redescende vite pour
répondre le chat genre mire ouais c'est
un très bon joueur qui va beaucoup les
arénas king et qui me battait à chaque
fois des fois je me disais même si c'est
plus intéressant d'abandonner avant la
partie en fait pour jouer d'autres parce
que non plus à vrai c'était décourageant
parce que ça m'arrivait dit ne te
rentrer dans une finale et cavaliers 3g
trois fous j'ai deux des trois ces
quatre là où tu fais des cdc dame prend
des fêtes ça m'est arrivé de lui tenir
pendant six minutes cette finale est de
faire nul à la petite nullos mais en
fait épuisé à la fin de ce truc là je
vois être rejoué avec for wii fit a
perdu 6 minutes à marquer un point ça
sert à rien mais en fait vous même c'est
que si tu abandonnes c'est quand même
complètement con ici chez tu sais jamais
quoi faire donc du coup après j'ai
attaqué comme un débile et une batte et
et ça ça remet en jeu le plus à rien
coiffe je veux aborder de la baisse est
tombé à l'édition de ces géniales il
serait super fier je crois il dit
pourquoi je joue mais en fait il a
raison enfin ça fait chier tu vas jouer
enfin je pense même à paris il a dû être
très tellement heureux de voir sa petite
répétition mais c'est bon alors mais tu
penses à duda même s'il doit réfléchir
une minute aussi quoi
il a raison et j'espère a tous fait
pareil je suis très longtemps je revis
très bas et très content que heavy rain
je suis très pragmatique m'isoler so far
so good
est ce qu'il ya des beats après non là
ce soir je vis de toi ça reprendra quand
l'écart très bientôt vers le 20 novembre
dizaine de jours mais il reste encore
des huitièmes la hâte en bas il reste
encore beaucoup de huitième la fab
tu m'as l'air d'oublier les hikaru
nakamura martirossian et les matches
comme ça ah oui oui non mais il reste
deux jours arménien c'est qu'il deuxième
à ses débuts chez les van leeuwen bon
dépôt c'est quand même un gros choc qu
au premier tour ça oui oui non mais oui
il sait moulian va vouloir une victoire
de serre gardant de chati c'est mouiller
en faillite est ici pas de base mais
depuis il veut qu'on l'appelle lycée
moulian parce qu'il est aussi un grand
supporter de tous les jours arménien a
donc eu comme nouveau tigre à nice et
mouillant mais je crois qu'en fait
maintenant tous les gens sont fans des
arméniens déclaré on est très heureux
même maxime notoire qui faisait son
roddick oui oui j'aurais arménien
contemporain 10éme oubliant fin de
chaque n'était même plus vraiment sûr
mais pour maxime fawi avec votre été
hissé mouliom l'air terrible ce joueur
c'est terrible ce un ennemi qui est 2008
chasse comme je le mets 15 ans et j'ai
une finale deux tours trois pions contre
3g une seconde 2 contre 13 secondes il
propose nul ouais j'ai immédiatement
envoyer un rapport de calais match comme
pour qu'on dégage ce joueur je ne
comprends pourquoi tu proposes nul avec
11 secondes contre eux une fois tu vas
le faire tomber
donc du coup j'ai fait nul et après j'ai
complètement tilt et j'ai continué le
joueur j'ai dit non mais je ne veux pas
jouer contre des gens pareils je ne
comprends pas il m'a complètement battu
et contre maxime aussi le mec te fait de
l'excès de fer pelé toulouse quoi fin du
coup on a voulu le ban coiffe les
rapports sont partis quoi maintenant il
faudrait que le fair play en fait
bon ben on l'a pas très très bien pris
je te le dis tout de suite là c'est bien
mais ce qu'il a fait à d'où je fais un
petit matin des escaliers s'il peut
toujours je sais tout je sais pas quoi
c'était bien joué là fabien les visages
ce qui en est très très très fort grand
maître d'ibiza dans le hockey enfin je
sais pas c'est le délire derrière mais
le pour une fois que tu y as milk
cercles sur un tas de ses biens ben
justement pourquoi des fair play en fait
je pense avec normal quoi oui mais
pourquoi tenait enfin je ne m'adresse
pas et anormalité coiffe un fils de [ __ ]
qu est ce que tu me fais quoi non mais
il est le mec le mec a été le mec a été
a été reportée immédiatement bas qui m'a
écrit après j'ai parlé de parti oui mais
aussi ses mérites et pourquoi je vous
tue compte des gens pareils enfin à se
lasser c'était très très énervé quand
même pourquoi tu joues en fait c'est
quelqu'un de très bizarre on ne comprend
pas quoi mais max linder à du musée
juste un mec qui joue sur internet pour
progresser pas revu depuis six mois oui
il fait des gaffes et wesley il a
tellement envie que son fils et sa fille
valentine seconde en bonne forme et
c'est sur i-tele oui j'ai calculé que
ces pauses se faire autant chi
je suis tellement fier c'est
extraordinaire presse visite en corée
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup à ce
format ta personne qui aime les joueurs
est en fait le seul qui est bien c'est
hikaru parce qu'ils incitent les rushs
il est bien sûr aussi non ouais
rennes n'est pas content parce que
personne ne lira format est génial
connaissez-vous même guéri j'ai vu le
clip quoi ah oui enfin le format est
quand même vraiment très bien enfin fou
tu sens qu'il est super bien payés et où
donc est obligé de dire oui mais enfin
bon ça sent qu'il n'a pas du tout envie
de dire oui en fait ça vient pas du
coeur pendant huit ans c'est clair mais
pourquoi heureux du jour en fait
bizarrement là encore c max qui en
savait plus que nous parce qu'il connaît
mieux la génèse du truc en fait c'était
très content du format quand il faisait
les deathmatch à l'époque je peste a
déjà regardé ça il ya peut-être huit ans
sur ce je me souviens enfin j'aime pas
pour ce marché la wii le nom de je
connais d'être mature en fait c'était
c'était super bien là pour la peine le
format était vraiment bon parce que
c'était le même format mais il prenait
deux mecs du même niveau et il savait
que ça allait rejeter max ouais moi du
coup le format était géniale et moi
j'adorais faire il y avait jamais vu
andré qui le comblait monorail avait
même fait l'icao enfin il faisait des
beaux matchs et des films étaient des
mecs un peu moins fort mais du même
niveau
tiens ça pouvait être un fine gueule
contre 1
contrat saimone williams o s qui s'était
clash et oui on va bien être sûr de qui
est le plus fort et du coup il y avait
une storytelling derrière c'était
vachement et au lieu de se dire oui bon
on fait le format est très bien mais ok
ouais en fait c'est non formelle génial
c'est notre format maison fantastique
moi le maître de partout et que c'est
pas le format qui est mauvais en soit le
format il est même assez intéressant
mais c'est le fait de l'utiliser panacée
pour comment ouais ça dépend comment
fais tu là typiquement à partir des
quarts de finale le format va être bien
en réalité
mais le truc c'est que l'armée en fait
en gros pour que s'ils sont si attachés
au format justement envie de faire et il
garder le même été une porte de sortie
quand il ya un carnage caezar et voilà
et +7 sais plus si c'est plus quelque
chose là-bas fin du match comme un chaos
works le match et les durées sont ces
durées très grande mais bon bastia cas
où il ya car vos bombes à allah veut
faire un truc un peu comme ça quoi ouais
c'est sûr du coup quand un pierrot déjà
fait d'oser as tu vas jusqu'au bout et
granta ça s'est fini en fait là ce
serait sont affiliés aux trois plus un
il ya à peu près une petite heure quand
il a pris six points d'écart et c'était
très bien en fait mais bon là quand tu
as martirossian contre contre ouais là
ça va faire mal
et d'ailleurs c'est même bien dans les
matches quand tu penses les matches
n'est peau contre les bonnes ou les
bonnes pour peut se faire reprendre six
points en bullet
en fait tu donne une chance à lemond
écrasé le garant blitz et de tu vois je
trouve que c'est même bien dans les
matchs où il peut y avoir un
retournement bullet des enquêtes étaient
trop nuls on glisse bras tant pis pour
toi en fait c'est pas après tu vas pas
gagné parce que tu es rapide avec ta
souris fin à tant pis pour toi et c'est
tant mieux en fait
donc oui le truc du cas où ce serait
bien mais je sais pas ils sont vraiment
fiers du truc tu as pourtant ta karl
scène guy fatat même guy ritchie a même
karlsson a dit que c'est bien aimé lui
en fait il n'a en fait non je dépasse
première grande scène là dessus c'est
c'est marrant quoi ça fait vraiment il
est maintenue si les écoles ouais je
sais plus exactement on en gros que le
match aurait dû s'arrêter bien avant que
logique si génial quoi soutenir qui
répète à fond pour que la partie dure le
plus longtemps possible c'est
extraordinaire alors oui mais en gros en
gros en tête depuis que yesso gritche au
québec
il a fait ça il sera toujours mettre la
puce à l'oreille de se dire oui bon il
ya un problème dans ce qu'on fait non on
faire encore plus d'ailleurs c'est un
peu dommage que la compétition est super
et ça va être bien à partir des quarts
c'est un peu dommage de d'abîmer un peu
la compet comme ça en fait mais bon
c'est comme ça mais en fait je pense
qu'il est très content so2 pas la gagner
là oui je reviens je pense objectif
c'est le minimum deux parties possible
d'aller pioncer
on en est où là au niveau audio temps on
en est il reste il reste il reste six
militaires à quelqu'un dit oui mais même
en fait si quelqu un revenu de plus 6
bat tant pis amis russes en fait on peut
faire une règle de dire bah en fait faut
jamais être mené de +6 points parce que
t k o en fait t'as pas perdu c'est
dommage mais tf1
moi j'avais une autre proposition c'est
à n'importe quel moment tu gagnes cinq
parties d'affilée ça met ko
du coup même si le magnificat ennemis
cat et demi en fait tu peux ok si on
veut faire un truc marrant du vous
garder un intérêt tout le temps atteint
ce rang 5 0 bull est un moment donné ça
peut arriver en fait un pas tu as perdu
le match
bon ben ok c'est un truc pour garder un
peu d'intérêt mais plus si je crois mais
j'ai pas mal le seul qui est revenu d'un
gros score c'était maxime contre eux oui
et s'il y avait une règle pareil il
aurait jamais été mené beaucoup en fait
ça le truc aussi donc normalement je
crois que à partir de +4 tu remontes
jamais en fait
enfin bon peu importe mais y aurait
quelques possibilités différentes pour
améliorer le truc assez simplement et
messer banquise est pas parce qu en fait
l'essence du thé ce match je me disais
ça a été vraiment des matches très
équilibré donc du coup en fait tu t'en
fous tu es que ça dure longtemps
ça devait jamais faire de massacres en
quoi en quoi que ce soit ah bon je sais
pas je sais un mystère pour moi
c'est marseille un peu plus que c'est
extraordinaire peu plus et ça c'est
super j'ai rarement vu vécu un peu plus
que ça may-carles scène sa gelée super
chez aussi un peu dans le même style
comme disait encore le format il va être
sympa à partir des quarts normalement
enfin en tout cas dans les quartiers
doit avoir au moins deux matches sur
quatre qui seront bien et les demies et
la finale c'est toujours sympa donc ça
devrait aller takahashi bonjour je viens
voir si on est bien sûr ça va ça va on
est relativement sûr encore quand une
dizaine de minutes et l'on sera très bon
sur j'en ai bien sûr partie je pense à y
aller plus vite son prochain match crois
que c'est mercredi n'est poireau ya la
triche
d'ailleurs tu es toujours au bon endroit
pour le faire ce que si jamais c'est toi
je te dire je sais célèbre tueur des
ménages non à moto je vais rentrer en
france
france france métropolitaine quoi
n'était pas à 100 c'est rentré de 22,6
web peut raccourcir le truc donc un bel
internet de la fouillouse son attention
mais a dû rentrer quand a du coup tu as
un timbre ajustements dans la semaine
donc possible justement que ce mercredi
mais ce bon là je te dirai rien tu me
diras tu donc bon ben voilà on a une
belle position et qui avait contenu les
fous à la nage
ces mots sont bien ça c'est sûr non
c'était bien que je sois là évidemment
j'étais j'étais tranquille c'était de
bonnes vacances bon faut bien rentrer de
façon tu vas bien t'amuser en france
ouais bah s'amuser cinq grands mots je
sois solidaire avec vous dans le
confinement
ces tests appelle ça un confinement
après ouais j'ai l'impression que c'est
pas une ambition ça le nom confinement
mais écoute comme je suis pas sur place
je veux critiquer non mais ça a le don
de moelle année
mondial de l'extérieur ça le nom de
confinement mais ils appellent ça un
confinement léger je crois du coup de
main mais oui oui non c'est pas bon on
va pas retourner dans cette morosité
parce que c'est ça faire sourire
personne
weight à tous les gens qui vont bosser
tu en fais ta part à part les
restaurants et les boutiques à touques
et ouvert quoi en fait
bah ouais mais c'est vous a pas chez moi
je suis pas trop je vous prends qu'il
prend ses cinq problèmes qu un plus
notre problème à ce que pour pour m 2
peu après pour lui ça va être encore
pire si on voit qu'il en a marre et tout
mais pourra tout ça est en fait sur ton
âme arbres en plus je fais défoncer et
coiffe un petit à faire du kg 6 pi et
fiable pour bien faire mais je pense que
j'ai tissé même plus vraiment de gagner
c'est vrai que ça durera longtemps je
pense vraiment que je vais ici sur la
partie longue possible il va enlever le
moins possible quand il va
[Musique]
ses avocats savent toujours pas gagné en
fait l'eau c'est le fun forteresse wesh
pas bien remarqué g7 revenir mettre
longtemps à rentrer rh 4 mai maxime
voudra organiser une partie de 5000 coup
à la fin pour faire durer le truc une
heure et tout est cette idée qu il est
et je contacterai il va peut-être même
la perdre en fait en voulant bien la
jouer c'est ridicule
enfin cas et c'est ça qui apprend à
verdi tombe
c'est d'ailleurs en train de regarder
l'écran il est absent je suis tombé et
ai pas vus il est tellement au bout du
bout quoi c'est vous qui allez les deux
ils savent pas ce qui se passe ici
schiste c'est magnifique on les comprend
aussi c'est dur pour tout le monde
d'ailleurs on vous enverra leur est
directement vers thiès comme après pour
écouter les interviews d'après match
mais ça peut être pas mal n'empêche son
goût du beau monde donc ok c'est un peu
un besoin tout à l'heure sauf que tout
allait changer du fou je prends des 5 et
ça l'est pas du tout c'est certes avec
faire tour b 8e faire du coup là il a
plus grands coiffeurs et puisqu'une 15
il peut la perdre tranquille pas
ça met une petite victoire qui s'appuie
se disent un peu comme prévu pour le
prono pour le pronom exactement non mais
l'interview de saut peut être pas même
faille peut parler de pipi n'eurent pas
peur ça non mais ça peut valoir le coup
donc
bâle et la replacer l'oeuf ou de ses
côtés mais bon jusqu'à quand non c'est
intéressant comme punition pour coup ben
c'est dommage que ça va rires mais il
s'intéresse en civ essayé de l'attaquer
sont rois j'ai pas je me mis à les
blancs mais voiture saint fons et 5 les
décoratifs et car ayant eu cathy met la
pression
en fait encore état d'affaires à 5 à 4 à
3 mon attente le projet mais s'être un
peu lent pour accueillir les cases
noires et l'at on fout du coup ils
soient ils sont très forts suivant son
projet c'est tenir encore cinq secondes
ce qui va se faire mater mais à savoir
times au pied très haut débit n'était
pas au courant de time's up et essayer
de résister encore quelques coups
d'éclat comme vite ça va je n'abandonne
c'est bon quoi ouais bah oui il avait
reçu un message de la partie la bande a
sévi est très vite abandonnées et très
heureux quoi bon très bien c'était ma en
fait ce sont deux bulles est du coup les
deux qui ferait pas mais c'est peut-être
qu'il va réussir en cinq plus sa tête
qui servent à ça commençait déjà à le
faire chier puis à pois blancs sauf si
le choc on sait pas qui bon bah du coup
fabas on va pas on va pas traîner dans
le sens souvent envoyé un raid et
quoique pourrez commenter le commentaire
donc rester bien aussi et on se retrouve
on se retrouve mercredi pour de nouveaux
speech est pour une nouvelle aventure
merci et leur aide par tout de suite je
peux même l'envoyer avant comme acer est
vers une autre chaîne
on est bien sûr sa part bonne soirée
tout le monde